the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the heat is on and the boards are
sizzling at the u.s juniors and senior
championships in saint louis after a
viciously decisive first round the
leaders hope to stay hot going into the
second day sophie morris suzuki is
making the most of her event winning her
second straight game for the top spot on
the leaderboard u.s legend larry
christensen won his first game tying
igor novakov for the lead of the senior
section but it's andrew hong who has
impressed with stellar preparation
definitely winning his first two games
to claim first place in the juniors the
pieces are placed and the clocks are set
round three of camp miss chess
coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day three of
the u.s junior and u.s senior chess
championships held here at the st louis
chess club it's a beautiful day here in
the central west end as we start our
journey in front of the tallest chess
piece in the world the players are ready
to battle it all out for a domination on
the chessboard let's go to the studio
and start this exciting round
hello everybody and welcome back to
saint louis missouri the capital of
chess in america as we bring you three
national championships the 2022 u.s
junior u.s junior girls and senior
championships are being played for this
week at the st louis chess club to bring
you all of that action and grand master
alejandro ramirez with grand master yes
sir sarah juan alejandro as always a
great pleasure to call all the action
with you and christian it's been
wonderful it's been great only two
rounds but that means 30 full games of
chess and they've all gone the distance
yes they have hello everyone and thank
you for joining us for this round three
of competition in our three national
championships it's been wonderful
really really
good fighting chess and one andrew hung
has really impressed with his
outstanding world-class preparation
alejandro
do the honors where do we stand in the
girls in the ladies section we have a
clear leader with us with two points out
of two sophie worry suzuki has impressed
she beat rochelle wu yesterday with very
strong preparation in a benoni type
king's indian but she's followed closely
by talia cervantes and ellen wang who
both have one and a half points whereas
jennifer you our pre-tournament favorite
at languishing with only two draws and
then the juniors in the junior section
we also have one player at the top with
two
points and that is our greatly prepared
andrew hung absolutely he's been
scintillating with his opening prep in
round one against david brosky and in
round two against balaji dagupathi just
blowing his opponents off the board with
great prep but he is trailed by only
half a point by christopher you and
adjusting wang meanwhile the tournament
leader or the first sea rather yes i
wonder liang languishing in uh seventh
place with half a point wow not easy
being a favorites and in the seniors
nobody isn't 100 anymore but we do have
two people at the top as larry
christensen and igor navikov what have
one and a half points each they are the
only people that have won a game except
for vladimir akopian who also won
yesterday but remember that he started
the tournament with a loss absolutely
and our format for these three national
championships they're ten player round
robins each 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game at a 30 second increment from move
one we have a traditional
classical time control here no draw
offers before the 30th move one point
for a win half a point for a draw zero
point for a loss traditional scoring
system and now nine rounds of play what
are their schedule their schedule is
simple one round a day played at 1pm
central every single day except for july
12th that is going to be our rest day
wonderful and of course as always
christian in studio to tell us about
today's gladiator gladiator uh good
morning christian good morning guys uh
great to be back in the studio with you
casting the games of the best juniors as
well as the best legends on american
soil and yesterday we did the profile of
one carissa but today i'm taking my eyes
onto the senior section where we have
one larry christensen grandmaster larry
christensen from massachusetts and let's
take a look at some of the highlights of
his illustrious career well he is one of
the few players to skip the
international master title on his way to
grand master he jumped directly from
feeder master to grand master this just
goes to show how talented this man is
he's also the three-time us champion
winning the event in 1980 1983 and most
recently in
2002 and the highlights continue he's
also very famous for his attacking style
he's also an author he authored two
books storming the barricades as well as
the sequel rocking the ramparts in 2004
those are some uh great book names he
was also inducted in the us chess hall
of fame in 2008 and currently teaches
chess in cambridge massachusetts and if
you want to get a game against him well
you can definitely find him on the
online spheres as well in all of those
platforms he's also quite a funny guy
and let's take a look at a video from
yesterday's interview
how did you rate your own chances
seriously i'll be honest can i have
modest goals here
how i just said you have a well i'm
actually more concerned about you know
breaking three million six hundred and
fifty thousand steps
for the year of 2022. oh wow say what
yeah look i'm a nut a nut on this whole
thing this is so what are you using
[Music]
yeah the application so i have to add my
numbers
walking around the tournament hall it's
one of the you know another gm quirk
well he's a funny guy and a fierce
competitor and we've seen that yesterday
what a tremendous victory with the black
pieces he had and today another big
round for him but for all the other
players as well because all of the
players are just amazing truly
and uh
do the honors uh set the table for our
viewers for the pairings for this round
three and let's start with the girls
let's start with the young ladies as we
have great matchups here i think the
most important ones will be ellen wang
with the white pieces play facing
against number one see jennifer you and
our leader sophie mori suzuki has a
great opportunity in my opinion with the
white pieces to extend her lead against
a wfm gracie prasanna nice and in the
juniors in the junior section we also
have important matchups but i think the
key one is going to be that second one
in your screen justin wang with one and
a half points is facing against andrew
hong with two he finally gets the black
pieces let's see if he shows any
weakness with that color absolutely
carissa yep for the first time getting
the white pieces let's see how she will
do in her contest against grandmaster
jacobson and in the seniors in the
seniors we have a bunch of interesting
games but i think the one to highlight
is there at the top larry christensen
with one and a half points will be
facing uh nick defermion also who has
one point and they've been playing
against each other in u.s championships
forever for 50 years both both players
hailing from the great state of
california uh going at it once more but
also i'm going to keep my eye on the
game between igor novikov also our code
leader as he goes up against a wounded
uh shabbalah we'll see if shibalov can
recover after tough loss yesterday a
very tough loss indeed and finally
getting the white pieces as well it'll
be his first white of the event
absolutely and of course they're
fighting uh rather hard
and they're fighting for lots of money
as the players you see they're getting
seated
uh getting ready to start this the third
round let's start with the prize money
for the girls and the in the girls
section we have twenty thousand six
hundred dollars for first place six uh a
total price one first place is six
thousand dollars second is four thousand
and third is three thousand meanwhile in
the junior section we have a forty
thousand dollar prize fund twelve
thousand dollar goes to first eight
thousand to second five thousand to 3rd
and in the senior championship
we have a bunch of money 75 grand total
20 000 of those going to first place
very impressive very handsome and the
players certainly appreciative of the st
louis chess club and scholastic center
for all that they do to support these
national championships
we have a bit of a rainy cloudy day this
is a shot of the central west the saint
louis chess club actually at the very
end of the st louis chess club not quite
this is actually the vodka bar sub-zero
that's the other side this is the other
side this is what we're using we're
using this as a temporary playing hall
when you said vodka bar that was like
the seniors what are you doing to our
seniors
it's a total remodel going on so we have
a couple of temp uh locations one of
them is our playing hall for this
tournament specifically we got a little
lucky that we're able to lease the space
christian i think they busted you
because they said we're here yeah they
this is a beautiful day here in
the west end and then they show you the
reality well look guys i cannot teleport
from doing the opens to jumping in the
studio those opens aren't live
i'm not revealing any professional
secrets of course
of course of course absolutely uh well
uh as
you saw there the players are getting uh
s settle down i just wanted to ask
yourself does you
start a big game
in any major tournament do you guys have
butterflies in your tummy at the very
start of play i think so but it goes
away
once you make your first couple of moves
yeah and then you kind of get in you
settle in yeah i think that's when i
settled in i've made a couple moves on
the board and i figured okay
the opening i know where it's going yeah
i can start thinking about chess and not
worry about results or standings or
anything like that christian uh i would
say the nervousness for you at the very
start absolutely yes and i would say um
that's mostly my fault because i tend to
prepare all the way until the last few
seconds
and
then i run to the playing hall most of
the times i'm like two three minutes
late and then for the first few moves
i'm just trying to kind of slow my heart
rate down adjust
the pieces and take it slow but after
the first few moves as alejandro also
pointed out
the butterflies usually go away nice i
just saw in that screenshot there you
had of larry christensen nick the
fermion larry opening knight f3 i mean
for a guy who's really you know got this
great reputation as a real aggressor
he's kind of been playing a little lazy
man's chest with b3 and uh g3 uh nick on
the other hand always throughout his
whole life really booked up he's
probably what goes through his mind at
this moment he could play almost any
defense i mean it's really ridiculous
yeah that's the problem right that when
you play everything you have to choose
you got you need one it's really nice
when you get the students that only play
one thing yeah what are we playing today
we're playing the kings indian is it our
only choice yup all right
nope nope
that's it
nothing else to say but c5 as
nick has been a long long long time open
sicilian player
so
so c7 c5 kind of expected i would think
larry will go into some english with c2
c4 i don't see him playing the move e2
e4 and challenging nick on his shall we
say home turf it's kind of funny
transposition right because it's kind of
a total change of approach from the
position go knight f3 c5 and then you
know what sicilian it is right vladimir
kramnik wrong-footed me once uh he
opened knight f3 and i know that
vladimir likes to play knight f3 d4 move
orders so i played c5
and he played e4
ourselves completely out he got the best
of me in that one but uh yeah c5
invitation and what do you have for us i
think he played also b3 right in the
first game right not mistaken
did he start with b3 at move one yes he
started with b3 and then followed up
with knight to f3 so i think these are
the type of structures that he's hinting
towards now the question is what are the
differences uh from that game with this
move c5 on the board now d5 is not yet
there right so we've seen what happened
in that game when black played the move
d5 now with the pawn still on d7 black
has extra options potentially trying to
go with d6 followed by e5 if you do
decide to go for a b3 and uh fianchetto
the bishop on the long diagonal cover
along the diagonal with this idea of d6
e5 let's see where this game takes us
yeah i remember a game walter brown
versus
anatoly karpov knight f3 c5 b3 g6
that was like a kind of an in in your
face move
uh bishop b2 c4 all right six
bishop takes
pawn tags
and the square d5 there was a big fight
over the square d5 how they came in and
it's a little karpov one
um c4 uh again i kind of expected that
larry is going to go in this direction
but christian
um
these guys are slow playing it who who's
who's hitting the ample while it's hot
where do we see a lot of moves we'll
stick
with the senior section we have a
sicilian in the game uh between vladimir
kopian and dmitry guravich another
richter rouser and we've seen what
happened in the first round we had
couple of rousers if i remember
correctly abhimanyu mishra
played some sort of a classical sicilian
against carissa abe as well as vladimir
akopian versus if i'm not mistaken
novikov and he got a winning position
with the white pieces in that game
unfortunately for him he was unable to
convert not only that but he fell under
tremendous pressure and actually
succumbed to black's attack now what
we're seeing right now is another
theoretical battle
and this is quite interesting because
you know you don't see this type of
ideas in the seniors uh
section most of the times we know that
they know old school theory and they
don't spend that much time on their
opening preparation
but it does seem like for this specific
tournament they spend quite a lot of
time on their opening preparation
because i mean going into these type of
sharp lines and dimitri is not shying
away
from them f4 is on the board let's wait
and see what's going to happen in this
one another blazing hot game uh
developing is the one between igor
novikov and alexander chabot you were
mentioning you will have your eyes on
this one for very good reasons because
we know alexander chabalov is a very
aggressive player he loves to attack he
loves to create imbalances and this is
exactly as early on uh as we see in this
game the king's indian with the setup
with a6 knight to c6 against the zemisch
this is going to be a very intriguing
battle let's wait and see how this one
develops i have a feeling we're going to
see some long castle followed by
a monstrous attack on the king side this
one is going to be a lot of fun guys
thank you for that and i just want to
look at the game of joel benjamin for a
second versus gregory kaidanov c4 e7 e6
right okay everybody's happy okay let's
go into a queen's gambit decline let's
go into it nimzo
e to e4
say what
what
yes d5
we take twice so we're in a french
defense suddenly and exchange french
with c4
right okay i know this position with c7
fun on e7 right right exactly uh that
will be your karaoke that's an id.com
bishop what is it
thank you because that's exactly what i
wanted to ask christian i mean we've
been talking in these broadcasts about
how openings get names some really funky
funny names
but i've never seen this
this is the seniors too it's like
they've been around i don't even know
what to call this uh christian bail me
out it's called the steiner variation
this style
variation yes i've never heard earlier
in the uh 50s hermensteiner right i
would assume so yeah
wow
okay
there are some really interesting games
uh is this line vashier versus fabiano
it does seem like vacher really likes to
play this with the white pieces
sargassian played it against um vashir a
lot of top-level games
yes absolutely so
yes this is no joke
all right well happy to hear the steiner
variation
yes 1948 how do i not know this person
hello come on man
history you know i know
i know you guys only think about the
history of today yeah
computers and electronics right exactly
exactly just checking in on the game
between justin wang and
andrew
hung for a moment as andrew as white has
absolutely
regaled us with his opening preparation
right now we're in a symmetrical english
i wanted to go to the game of brandon
for a moment yeah i think that owen is
the most fun right now carissa
this is the game between chris egypt and
brandon jacobson and it's smack
piano smells of levon eronion right yeah
king h8 h3 whoa f5 yes and look at
brandon he's like
underneath that mask there's a smile
because i'm pretty sure we're in his
prep oh yeah definitely this must have
been played before but i have no idea
of the theoretical
it's it's definitely really good for
christian has been played before yes it
does seem like at the top level has been
played between topalov and nakamura and
more recently by alexeyenko and dingley
wren and i do assume that that game was
actually from the candidates if i'm not
mistaken i think that's the world cup
perhaps the world cup yeah i'm sure with
that one
take take us through what carissa uh is
experiencing right now she's put a rook
on a2 to defend f2
she
she can't take the knight on g4
presumably hg fg is a kind of a suicide
mission yes no nobody has actually
played this and i would expect she's not
going i mean she knows that she cannot
take uh that night knight wage two
followed by g3 the queen is coming as
well this one is not looking good so you
cannot take that night that night is
taboo right now so help me out christian
what should carissa be doing
um well a lot of the games most of the
games in fact um have a followed out
with he takes if he takes f5 or knight
to f1 these are the two options e takes
f5 seems to be the main line by far and
that's when the far fun starts because
actually after he takes f5 the main move
is knight takes f2 right rook takes f2
bishop takes f2 bishop takes f2 bishop
takes f2 is one of the options bishop
takes f5 is uh another move in fact this
is a novelty apparently despite the fact
that it might be the best move of the
engine
information here guys
this
[Applause]
uh brandon jacobson has something uh
brewing and something prepared in this
line very deeply uh i would expect him
to play bishop to x5 after h3 if she
does go for this line now
perhaps you can play this move knight to
f1 the problem is that
take take and i have a feeling rook
takes f3 is going to come on the board
right now
this one is not looking good right
that's an exchange sacrifice this one is
going to fall to enjoy that's the
problem and we're going to see the exact
same thing that carissa did with the
black pieces yesterday right this idea
of queen e8 queen to h5 uh potential in
the position followed well maybe knight
h5 first to stop uh white from going
knight g3 if you do decide to defend
this pawn with king to h2 after a quint
d7 well unfortunately there's no more
defense against queen takes h3 this one
is not looking good for a white so you
cannot allow this
f5 she's thinking i'm sure she's not
thinking about taking this knight on g4
she needs to take on f5 and remember her
preparation
uh but
help me out here guys i'm white i'm
opening up the game
i've got the initiative i feel like
carissa
has been thrown back on the defensive
yes she has
did she do something wrong that black is
the one who's kind of pushing the action
well the problem with the joko piano is
that there are so many ways in which it
can be played by both sides right right
white and black and it does seem uh like
carissa did not produce any early
surprises did not produce any uh new
setups that brandon hasn't seen before
and it does seem like brandon did
especially with this king to h8 f5 idea
again there's so many things that you
need to prepare when you're preparing
the joko piano that it's pretty much
impossible uh to have everything
memorized and unfortunately for her this
one slipped away this variation yeah
maybe that move knight bd2 is just not
accurate here maybe h2h3 yeah necessary
yeah something yeah because i i mean
it's weird when you're white right yeah
you're already being pushed back so
early like how is that and f5 is really
a challenging move it feels like if you
can get away with the move at five
you've done something off as white then
you shouldn't be allowing an expansion
this quickly so successfully it should
have some kind of drawback right
exactly if i remember correctly i
actually played a very similar game to
this one perhaps even in this position i
cannot find it in that base right now
but it was against bachmann axel
bachmann in one of the collegiate events
and i played with the black pieces and
we got to this position and i had no
problems equalizing the position i had
the initiative for most of the games but
most of the game but he managed to
escape so
quite an intriguing position but i have
to say brandon jacobson has won the
battle of the opening right just looking
at the game of david brodsky for a
moment
i'm sorry i'm going to get his
opponent's name all wrong bail me out
here
that's the man
that's what i wanted to say i just
couldn't say it
boy they're blitzing out
this open sicilian theory like there's
no tomorrow
am i seeing another richter rouser
yeah what's what's going on you know
like the richter roster was dead for
like
decades decades nobody nobody was
playing the richter rouser and suddenly
we're seeing it in the seniors like uh
you were mentioning christian a number
of games besides the concerts too
there's been a lot of them yeah we saw
it was just looking yesterday we saw
carissa played against
you i can count like five or six
classical sicilians in this tournament
alone exactly yeah and then after the
move b7 b5 this is where white pounced
and said okay now
that your bishop is no longer anchored
and protected by the pawn on b7 i was
waiting for that move so i could play
takes
you're welcome to sacrifice a pawn he
took it and i
i'm guessing this is all still theory uh
alejandro i see your database as having
four games four okay big names any um
gigaco sorry it's just the biggest names
i can find from that list uh that game
followed queen b6 which looks
less automatic i mean you want to
protect
this bishop
eyeballing this night i kind of want to
get it out of there
can i uh chase it away yeah it all comes
it all kind of hinges if i can play rook
fda okay i don't show rook out for
rookie but i assume later you can decide
which one you'd like to keep kicking you
around the game actually followed that
way the one that we're talking about
your galco against and just bishop e7
and that was the game this is this is
how it's gone yeah wow interesting stuff
very very intriguing preparation uh
by
balaji it seems like like he got caught
i can do that
yes he got i can't do that
i'll do balaji i i i can do it because
he was my student when he was uh just
like 10 year old kid now he's taller
than me um
and i actually saw him today in the
morning at the gym and he was working
out and i asked him about the
preparation and it seemed like it was
going quite well so definitely it seems
like he has surprised his opponent now
this is the type of preparation that you
actually want to have in your games
because if you look at the engine and
other results as well black is doing
tremendously well so often it is
overlooked by your opponent by the
player with the black pieces when
they're preparing this line because they
say okay queen takes this you cannot do
that you're just simply worse but if you
go deeper in the line queen to b6
knight to e5 seems to be the main line
knight takes bishop to c5 queen takes e5
now at least you don't have to fight
against the two bishops and you're also
an extra pawn so the next move comes
quite
naturally which is queen takes f2 knight
takes b5 and we get into this type of
position by the way decisions along the
way right because you don't
have to take on b5 nevertheless it does
seem like the knight is just simply
better than the bishop still a decision
that black has to make willingly and if
he doesn't know the theory then it's not
going to be that easy another uh step
where he can potentially falter bishop
takes b5 queen takes b5 queen takes g2
looks a bit scary right you're opening
up the files uh towards the king so now
queen to e2 or queen to e5 i have a
feeling queen to e5 might be the right
move now you see the engine is saying
black is slightly better 0.3 minus 0.3
nevertheless it's a very complex
position it also it's going to probably
come down to who's going to be able to
push their pawns faster and if white
knows and that is bellagio if he knows
what he has to do in this position well
i mean he's going to have a good
advantage over his opponent and nice
heads up in this line so i'm definitely
liking what i'm seeing from bellagi
very very nice i'm
looking also we were talking
what's popular these days well the joko
piano we just saw one variation of the
joko piano but in the game of wonder
liang and wender being black in this
game against mishra
i like the way white has played this
version of the joko piano as compared to
carissa
he's induced g5 which might be good for
black but now i really like this
maneuver of knight eight because it's
about the fi square right you've played
the moves g5 and e5 so the f5 square has
been left behind in the wake of the two
pawns
and the maneuver knight b1
to a3 to c2
to e3 and onwards to f5
really is
ideal you you you want to hit that f5
square
and if you could ever plant a knight
there it's wonderful so um again a
wonder liang
2700 he's coming in here saying guys i
all i want is
the first prize and a ticket to the us
championships he ain't getting it well
that's not so easy he's plenty of
tournament ahead for him he's got to
work hard
yeah and this is a tough pairing when
you think about it uh abhimanyu has had
such a great year it's hard to say
exactly how strong a bmi is these days
13. right i think it's 13 still yeah
international grand master breaking the
world's record
um
what a thrill yeah absolutely
at 13 i was playing in the washington
state junior championships
doing it
i think i tied for first oh there you go
there you go
we take those
wasn't a grand master norm i can tell
you that
yeah he'll tell you that where would you
like us to go uh let's take a look
around the horn a little bit let's start
with the juniors because uh yeah sure
they have quite quite a few interesting
games uh the carissa brandon jacobson
game we already saw this one there are
no changes uh balaji did play the move
knight e5 uh more or less along the
lines that we expect and then this game
between justin uh wang and andrew hong
it's they're playing some kind of kg
english where one side goes d5
so you want to take my pawn on the other
side it says no
i'll put my own pawn on d4 okay you want
to take it and we eventually reach this
end game which i think is is considered
to be okay
for black but maybe not a lot of fun but
yeah
it can be a little unpleasant to defend
these when you're not so familiar with
the positions well especially if white
ever
nicely recaptures the pawn with
something like knight e3 knight c4 i'm
sure black is going to throw in the move
c4 c3 when that eventuality but again
like you say if you get wrong-footed you
know bishop d2 bishop c3 knight e3 very
harmonious play for white and you could
be lost before you even
yeah
the the positional problems generated by
the pawn on c6 they creep up on you
pretty quickly yeah for example just to
play some bad moves for just a moment
and let's say you you decided that that
was the cat's meow and you wanted to
fianchetto your bishop on the long
diagonal well suddenly you start to
realize that
what have i really done at the end of
the day i'm the one with the split pawns
my structure
and white's pieces are all looking
better than blacks and you kind of say
what did i do wrong i'm in trouble keep
an eye on that game again andrew with a
2-0 start
looking good christopher with an
interesting approach to life
he's playing an exchange slot against
the lowest rated player in the
tournament i always figured this was an
interesting way of playing chess because
the exchange slap you think about it
very safe opening yeah you rarely lose
with the white pieces that's right you
don't convert that often it is pretty
symmetrical
is it a good weapon to play against
somebody that's three or four hundred
points lower rated than you
it's a question and i think people have
different answers to it yeah sometimes
when you're playing against a much lower
rated player you would like the game to
be a long long game and a game where
they haven't come where they're prepped
with their prep right 20 moves uh
keeping we'll keep an eye on this one as
well of course and then that was the one
this is the one all right
and christian over to you
just to go a really quick in the junior
girls section because the leader sophie
mauri suzuki is having another almost
perfect game up to this point so let's
take a look at what's happening we're
seeing the rui lopez c5 d4 and now
i'm looking at that base it says rue
lopez closed defense have you guys heard
about that from
my idea i thought it was called chigorim
that's how i know what are the
variations of the closed that's how i
know it's agoran with queen to c7 right
clean to season queen to c7 is the main
move but she decides to go for an early
c takes d4 c takes d4c takes d4 and only
now queen to c7 now we know after queen
to c7 most uh of the players play the
move knight to d2 and then you can take
on d4 take on d4 and all those lines
with knight to c6 this is long theory
long theory very long old-school theory
but
she decides to take on d4 first which
gives white an extra option after queen
to c7 knight to d2 obviously transposes
to the main lines but you also and it
seems like this probably is a better
move it hasn't been played as often as
knight to d2 but knight to c3 seems to
produce some very serious problems for a
black immediately targeting this square
d5 potentially bishop to d5 also knight
to d2 usually is followed up by knight
to f1 and knight to g3 you still have a
route to get your knight to g3 where you
want it via e2 and then to g3 now at the
same time it's just a much more
aggressive and much
more dynamic position for the knight and
she looks extremely relaxed look at her
she's just walking around eyeing the
position behind her opponent from an
eagle's
eye point of view
she looks great right now her position
is amazing and bishop to d7 bishop to b7
was played and immediately followed up
by d5 close the bishop away now that you
committed it to this diagonal i might as
well play the move d5 h6 knight wii to
play it quite quickly
rook to e8 i'm not 100 sure if i do like
this move rook to e8 in general i would
like this rook to go all the way to see
it and try to create believe the rook on
a8 because you're probably going to try
to expand on the queen side via push of
a5 a4 and try to create some unpleasant
reason now the problem is that the rooks
are kind of fighting for the same square
that is c8 so i think the rook on e8 is
worse placed than the rook on a that's
why i put this rook on c8 nevertheless
she decided to go rook to e8
knight to g3 and now back to c8 with the
bishop this is the last move i have to
say if you play bishop to b7 followed by
bishop to c8 something went wrong and
the engines are definitely agreeing with
this assessment plus 1.6
right now this is very close to a
decisive advantage for white as early as
move 16 and she hasn't spent any minutes
on her clock
sophie mori suzuki that is so i'm
definitely liking what i'm seeing from
her side wow a better understanding i
think overall of where your pieces
belong i felt that black had an idea of
where everything goes but not the
precise move order down i think the d5
takes c4 c5 takes d4 it was a slip yeah
i think her intention her prep was to
play queen c7 and then to play it
sometimes you get at the board you mix
it up and i think that's what's happened
and why white is enjoying an advantage
when i go to the senior section for a
moment go to the game of
max and igor
and
it's a london system but not a london
system that i'm used to seeing with
knight c3
c5 knight c3
knight f6 e4
and what the heck did we call this one
we just had to name that baby
the steiner
in the joe benjamin clash what do we
name this baby uh christian
the queen's pawn game steinitz counter
gambit
that was my third guess yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah
steinitz counter gambit i knew that
counter again
of course not i feel like i guess i
never saw this position
how did steinitz get his name attached
to this i have no idea i feel like i
don't know 99 percent of
these names that lichas is recommending
exactly what do we think about the
position guys i i had an idea let me
jump in i thought if you played queen a5
which has something to be said for
because you want to pick up the pawn
maybe you want to someday get an e5
i was thinking about taking the sight
say what
like that knight even hasn't moved and i
put my because i was wondering what you
guys thought of this
do i want to play a4 no i just want to
go into this i saw this position after
the move queen d5
sort of looks okay for black if i take
on c5 here with the queen i guess i
guess with the queen i'm
not
that greedy or yeah i might have sex and
no not have sex or squeeze questions
six is fine knight f6 is fine knight f6
is fine you're not afraid of uh cool
give me a check i'll play b5 and
oh no say my rook was useful
thank you very much
good fair enough fair enough it's a line
i think it's weird
it's a weird position
truly i've never i've never heard that
name before but actually why do we throw
in this bishop take speech of course
let's analyze this a little bit just
because it's such a weird position fun
yeah queen a5 i like throwing in the
check
immediately immediately okay
you play bishop d7 right correct
i have no any tricks exactly that was
my idea too maybe i just played queen e2
we need to and i want to castle next
move
okay
and
e7 e6 not sure if i take on
can i just look at this this is a little
bit crazy you take take take you gotta
go knight eighty-six i gotta go knight
a6 not the ideal square of course
castles i assume yeah okay he's well
now i don't want to play e6 because
there's a knight coming there
coming there right i wanted to play e6 i
couldn't find knight d5 but i
realized that you could jump on the
square d6 um
weird what is the uh
accepted
theory if you will uh christian
yeah theory is difficult to call this
theory but
it actually the analysis that you guys
were making was following one of the
games that has been played in this
position the game between grand deluxe
and pia crumbling actually so two great
swedish teams great sweets player
queen to a5 was the move and bishop to
b5 was the choice of grand delus it
doesn't seem like it's the most um
used in this position bishop to b5 queen
to d2 seems to be the better idea just
to be super fast with your development
and try to put as much pressure on your
opponent's king before they finish their
development so for example if you decide
to take a pawn take on c5 why not after
castle you're starting to have some very
serious problems with your development
because there's an immediate checkmate
coming on the board queen to d8 you have
to defend against that how do you do
that bishop to d7 seems to be like the
right idea but now we see the
misplacement of the queen on c5 and i
can target that immediately by trying to
recapture my pawn on e4 with the
maneuver knight to e2 followed by knight
to g3 followed by a knight to e4 and
it's very difficult to stop me from
doing that and finish your development
at the same time this is the key problem
that black is having in the position for
example another big problem after you
place the bishop on d7 is that you
cannot
naturally develop with the move knight
to c6 because this knight on f6 is what
we call an overloaded piece it defends
both the bishop d7 as well as the pawn
on e4 and the bishop on d7 is much more
important because
if i managed to get it
that's a checkmate right follow the
yellow brick road
so after 94 actually it's a resignation
time for a black you still have queen
five but that's just game over in a
couple of moves
it does seem like this is a very
dangerous position and by the way after
quite a significant thing he played the
move uh khmelnitsky that is bishop to g4
wow allowing the trade of the queens
like this queen takes a champion
this cannot be good for you to take
place enforcing i'm going to get castle
i can i can go h3 first i can go to f3
as well oh f3 there are so many options
right now and they all look terrible for
black so this bishop to g4 i think is
just
a huge mistake in the position and he
mis-evaluated this uh end game did not
understand that why species are just
coming with tempo exactly and i'm not
100 sure you're going to take this pawn
on c5 in the end game right not looking
good for black malnitsky is in huge
danger to just be completely losing out
of the opening absolutely uh just
finishing our uh tour of the seniors
games for a moment because that
herman steiner variation of the french
defense how you like me now baby
delivering the goods uh between joel
benjamin and gregory kaidanov have
reached a position where if i'm playing
a bullet game in i'm in joel's shoes
the automatic move here is a bishop to
c4 to b3 and i would call the position
about even the isolated queen pawn i've
got control of e5
but
if you
were all for anderson
i've seen off on numerous occasions make
just this very very same
exchange sacrifice where you take on e6
you go queen e2 and you play it very
very slowly as if you've got all the
time in the world but if you're joel
benjamin you're 1997 joel benjamin you
play bishop b3 like he did against paul
vander stern so joel has a pedigree in
this
very of nice he's actually played this
against not only vander stern but also
against christensen
whoa
okay bishop
okay should be three played bishop b3
played nothing new under the sun for joe
okay and it shows on the uh
on the time difference right joel's
still with about an hour 30. yeah it's
uh grisha kaidanov that's actually spent
his time exactly and i just wanted to go
to
larry and nick so this is the uh
a3 i
i'm gonna say that jonathan spielman
amongst others made this move a2 a3
popular uh bishop c5 e3 is a little bit
of a
maybe it's a main line uh e2 e3 stranger
than i know okay
and finally uh our
this is what we would call the four
pawns attack
igor
you usually you kind of move it over to
f4 you know look at them apples i mean
they're all in the center of the board
okay king's indian defense love to see
it by shabala the sameish variation
queen d2 knight c6 here there are a lot
of choices i'm going to say that
i believe oscar pano as uh first
uh attributed this knight c6 and i
actually know it as the pano variation
of the same ish exactly and b c7 c6 i
know as the burn
variation robert byrne
knight d7 as played by gary casparov in
the world championship match against
anatoly karpov knight c6 92 bishop d7
i'm kind of used to seeing actually rook
b8 and b5 rook b1 uh that's new for me
h565 we're in a different territory
planet different dimension i just saw
the white box and i thought it was funny
i just realized he played h5 completely
unprovoked right
so hold on wait a second if black now
follows up with h4 and g5 attacking on
the king's side and white goes a4 and b5
it turns my entire understanding or this
variation on its head down
e6 okay
okay
what do you mean okay i don't know what
the heck is going on i'm supposed to
come here and give commentary and i'm
like okay christian whenever i'm
clueless
which game are we following
you caught me off guard again because
i'm looking at a completely different uh
good for you
you guys need to analyze that one
without an engine right right but guys
we have such a huge battle brewing right
now between abimanu and awander liang
and i have to say
this is
maybe not the top rated uh battle in
this competition but nevertheless in
terms of trends
i'm looking at abby manuel and i'm
seeing him as one of the favorites of
the event and of course a wonder we know
that he's the rating favorite of the
event so this is a huge clash right now
happening and i have to say the position
will probably explode very soon so we
have another joko piano a completely
different type of joko piano we've seen
initially uh in the game of charissa
versus brandon jacobson with the pawn on
a4 with the pawn on a6 now you see a
completely different setup and this is
what i was talking about there's so many
ways in which you can play both with
white and black this joko piano and
let's take a look at how we got to this
position so
this early bishop to g5 started to
become somewhat of a trend recently
bishop to g5 setting up this pin
allowing black
to develop quickly with h6 and a g5 push
white species backwards nevertheless at
the same time creating some weaknesses
that later on white could potentially uh
target this pawn on h6 and a g5 at the
same time uh there is a big tradeoff
for white allowing this and that is
black is gaining a lot of space and it's
going to become quite uncomfortable to
move and maneuver your pieces around the
king side so let's take a look at what
happened bishop to a7 unprovoked bishop
to a7 because white most likely at some
point was going to target this bishop
with the move d4 so just in anticipation
of that let's go bishop to a7 bishop to
a7 knight to a3 bishop to g4 knight to
c2 and i really like this maneuver
knight 23 knight to c2
eyeing the square e3 this is where i
want to be this is where i want to be if
i manage to get two knights uh targeting
the square f5 because once again after
you play the move h6 and g5 a lot of
weaknesses you're leaving behind right
you have to be careful about that
h5 after a pretty significant thing by
this point
a wonder had one hour and 33 minutes and
48 seconds so that's quite uh a
substantial improvement based on one
hour and 30 minutes that he started with
after this move
h5 he spent it seems like 13 minutes
on this move so he did he was not aware
and by the way h5 is a novelty bishop to
ah5 was played before king to g7 was
played before i'm seeing a very recent
game between duda and anton guijaro
that is uh definitely the top level
clash in this position h5
and now
it does seem like if you don't play h3
you might be in trouble but my bishop h4
is coming right so you have to do
something right h3 makes the most sense
i guess the other uh
potential move would be to go h4
directly nevertheless it does seem that
after knight to h7 it is black who is
gaining the initiative i have a big
threat to take on h4 or take on f3 first
so you are in some sort of danger you
have to start with h3h4 you cannot
remove uh this bishop from the h5 d1
diagonal release the pin because the
pawn on g5 is going to hang so you have
to follow it up with h4 bishop to h2
bishop to h5 and this is the key
position and this is um a a big uh
ramification that white will have to
decide what path to follow because
king to h1 is a very subtle move wow
very pretty move
as well because hanging
hanging f2 right but actually after
bishop takes f2 queen to d2 is just game
over
very close to game over
exactly so you cannot touch this pawn
curses
on f2 now how do you develop your
initiative as a black maybe a g4 knight
takes h4
g3
sure and now you see the idea of king to
h1
with the king on g1
this position would have been winning
for black so let's just put it from the
beginning for example if you play
something like a4 g4 knight x h4 g3 the
game is pretty much over not that i'm
taking necessarily your bishop but i'm
also taking on f2 with the pawn follow
it up with uh capturing the rook on e1
devastating attack for black and
devastating material advantage so
such a beautiful move king to h1 i
really like it uh it's not the only one
though d4 is another move and it makes
much more sense at least from a human's
perspective i have to say probably i
would be personally inclined to play
this move at d4 first and then we're
going to get some sort of craziness
happening you're going to go g4 and now
i have options of actually just saying i
don't care about that knight
i'm just trying to get my queen in with
this move queen to d2 it's going to be
wild this one
if played
well by both players is going to be wild
and let's take a look at uh the profile
of this young man grand master abi manu
mishra only 13 years of age 2600 stop it
it's incredible that is amazing the
surge of uh this player through the
rankings the past year is just
magnificent that's true what does this
feed up to actually let me go check i
think 25 70.
because of the game that you're looking
at i also i was thinking that mishra
wanted to play the move knight e3 i
understand h3 and h4
but i thought his idea was to play
knight
e3
um
christian the idea is i don't think you
could play h4 my intention at least
was to take and take no but i can think
on f3 right
take a look
on f3 and h4 and then oh sorry right
here right yeah ah of course
that's i mean my piece right well i mean
maybe you get some some compensation
yeah i you know sometimes i over
estimate
you know i put a knight on f5 and i you
know i'm so proud of myself it's i mean
it is dangerous but it may be it is a
piece it's not that much in this
particular position right right right
right and then very specifically because
i can even go g4 right now do it can you
yes probably tonight
start
yeah
yeah uh sorry sorry um by the way uh
always a great pleasure of course we're
honored that you uh join our show and
watch us share share your day with us
tell your friends where you're hanging
out and also
we invite you to submit your questions
uh through our social media alejandro
join the conversation tweet at st louis
chess club or ask your questions is any
of the live chats we're monitoring all
of them we're on twitter we're on twitch
we're on youtube we're on instagram we
are even on facebook
apparently yeah and we have of course uh
former us women's champion sabina fosher
helping us out she is a journalist for
our event so uh show us your question
yeah we have one of them
from twitch user pac-man 2777 we are
seeing the u.s junior championships can
the panelists tell a story from when
they were in their junior playing day
i'd love to
my very first a junior championship was
in 1976 memphis tennessee i was 16 years
old i was really happy to play in those
days what was an eight
player field
um and was that a double round robin
single round round uh and uh what was
really fun was in those days uh mid 70s
i think there were about a hundred grand
masters in the entire world so to become
a grand master was a very very big deal
and we were like these young lions like
are you going to be a grand mass of
course i'm going to be a grandma of
course i'm going to be a grandmaster so
out of the eight players in the field
six became glaring masters
including nick defermion who's in
including john fedorowitz and two
players did not become international
grand masters and they were the winner
of the tournament mark diesen
who today if you win uh pardon me mark
diesen won the junior went on to the
world junior and won it
mark diesel became a world junior
champion today if you win the world
junior championship you get the title
automatically it is like you don't even
need to look at the other i am was uh
kenneth regan oh professor kenneth
yes exactly but we had john fedorwich
john tisdale who was a guest on the
candidate
yeah nick defermien michael road
um yeah like right like what a junior
i mean this is like
you know a hall of fame
junior championship from 1976 memphis
and uh
i remember it was a really wonderful
tournament
jim gallagher was the organ who was one
of the organizers and he took us to a
catfish restaurant
and we had catfish fried catfish it was
really good i never had it i mean i just
i mean you go you go to the south
but it was
it was very very special and i think
for a lot of junior players who've
played in these junior championships and
world junior championships they all have
stories of them how about yourself it's
hard not to right i didn't even play
many junior championships i only played
the under 14 in 2002 on the uh
under 20 in 2008
and
i met a lot of people that's what ends
up happening right like in your junior
tournament right you end up meeting tons
of people that you just know the rest of
your life exactly yeah because i mean
when was this tournament 50 years ago
and i saw you guys have a beer the other
day exactly like kingside diner right it
must be nice but for me it's something
similar i met that's how i met fabi
i was way i was in the world of junior
the world youth was back then world
youth under 14.
i was representing costa rica back then
and he was representing america right i
hadn't moved to europe yet
um
and i'm sitting in the lobby of the
hotel i'm just waiting to get checked in
my mom's with me so she's the one doing
the check-in and then this little
runt of a kid
speak for yourself
i was under 14. so i was you know one of
the international masters in the under
14 section we're not worthy oh yes this
kid was definitely not worthy it was
under 10 kid challenges made two blitz
of course and i thought all right i'll
just humor him and
beat him and he'll go away right but it
was a very close match i ended up
besting him
but it was really hard considering i was
four years older and i was like 300
points higher
that's scary it was pretty hard but fabi
fabio was fabio even back then dang
jump in and jumping christian because i
know you
have a number of uh world youth stories
yourself well the world youth uh i
played pretty much every year since i
think it was 1998 because from my
generation i was by far the top rated
player in my age group so i was always
qualifying because that's how you were
qualifying to be sent to the world youth
by winning the national championships
and uh but one funny story actually came
from a national championship if i
remember correctly we were playing this
uh ten player round robin and uh i was
playing against this like 10 year old
kid i was 10 year old yes as well and uh
he offered me a draw at some point and i
started thinking about the position and
as i was thinking about it i realized
that i'm probably just lost so i was
just about ready to accept the draw
offer and then he rescinded his draw for
he was like no no forget about it i i i
don't want to i don't want any drugs
anymore and i was like no that's not how
it works if we make a draw right now and
we go home i think he started crying and
i tried to explain the arbiter that he
did not offer a draw so it was like uh
he said she's a type of situation
but that was uh quite uh funny there's a
lot of crying in there there's a lot of
crying yeah i'm gonna borrow a page from
ben feingold i to just tell a very quick
story about the scholastics and this is
not a u.s junior championships this is
scholastics so ben feingold happened to
find himself at a scholastic event
and it was overwhelming there were too
many kids so the organizers said please
ben please please uh could you step in
and be an arbiter uh for the event ben
said sure i got nothing else to do
and the arbiter explains to the kids
that hey look if you have any issues
like what you just described
he said she said situation
raise your hand an international grand
master ben feingold will come to your
board and we'll make an executive
decision that sits
okay
gong within just seconds of the gong
like bang
you know kids
put up there
so ben goes and they've been playing
like doc
and the kid
ben comes over and he's looking
something's wrong
like white's being checked like four
different ways
and black's king is also being checked
for just different ways
and ben says what's going on kids and
the white the player with the white
pieces says well i think
he stalemated
because his king can't move
and ben said that's true and what do you
think
i think he stalemated his king can't
move
i think that's true said ben so what do
you guys think i think it's a draw said
the players and they shook hands
ben ran for the exits
never
he left the tournament all said i made
an executive decision
i thought that was hilarious these these
junior tournaments are very very special
they're and the memories are long lived
they're really unforgettable they are i
mean so many tears in the last round of
that event
i can only imagine it's just so many
hopes and dreams crushed and you see
them all the time
oh aviv
friedman
who is oftentimes a coach for these
teams of uh kids that goes to the head
of delegation there you go
i mean he's seen it all gold medals he
tossed away in the last round and it's
pretty bad i wanted to get an update on
the carissa yip game for just a moment
because that
karissa i think she went into deep uh
she went to a very deep thing
i think after f5 came up with the move
knight f1 but it didn't take she didn't
take on f5 but it's actually brandon now
that's in the think tank already
almost 20 minutes actually 22 minutes i
think already for brandon so clearly out
of his prep
we liked
d-e-f-f-e-d-e rook takes f3
it's not our rooks that we're i was
trying to sacrifice a rook for joel i'm
trying to sacrifice a rook for brandon
but this was pretty tempting but this is
very this was barely a sacrifice i mean
thanks for this bishop looking and we've
even mentioned queen d7 queen e8 queen
h5 as well as knight
h5 and i can't shake the feeling that
somehow carissa got put on the back foot
early
and
brandon is probably a happy camper now
the interesting thing about this
position is that the move knight f1 has
been seen at the top level of chess okay
and black in both top level games
there's also other games but in both top
level games they have replied f takes e4
d takes e4 and neither one of them
neither nakamura nor dingler n
found the move rook takes f3 well
obviously they found it but they didn't
play it they both dropped back one went
to f6 and the other one actually went to
h6 who went to h6 they learned
now they got the engine here
the engine hates that move
as a chess coach
if your student played the move knight
h6 and you your face explodes into some
kind of red
atomic bomb
and then they say but i was following
the game of dingler and what can you do
right right you gotta have your witty
remarks ready for that one exactly
exactly jump right in christian what
caught your attention well i was looking
at this game and taking on e4 and taking
on f3 is not the only way to go about it
actually knight to f6 was also uh played
at uh the top level game arian tari he
played it quite recently in 2018 knight
to f6 now this almost
forces the move because you have to
follow up your development right you
have to finish off your development the
problem is knight to g3 doesn't really
work because allowing f4 and then if you
go back queen to ea
a tremendous attack is coming your way
and you don't have enough forces to
defend so you cannot allow that
you have to take on f5 first and then
follow it up with knight to g3 and this
is probably the decision uh that uh
brandon jacobson is trying to make at
this point do you take on e4 and then
take on f3 and sacrifice and trying to
capture that sacrifice or you go for
this more tame approach but still it
does feel like black pretty much got
everything they wanted out of the
opening right knight to g3 i just go
bishop to g6 i don't have any problems
as black i'm the one setting up the
pressure and setting up the tempo in the
position so this is a very tempting
option as well and this is exactly why
he is thinking right now
in the abbey money versus a wonder game
they are indeed following the line that
we discussed after the move h5 h3 was
the move not h4 h4 bishop to h2 and now
bishop to h5
and we said this d4 was the human's
approach in our estimation but king to
h1 was a very intriguing move king to h1
i don't think we're going to see that on
the board now these are not the only
moves another very interesting idea is
to just simply target the pawn on g5
immediately with the move queen to d2
getting off the pin and at the same time
not allowing bishop to ace f3 because
after queen takes g5 well that's an
inter met so you're going to move at the
king then i'm probably going to pick
another one well probably just go queen
to uh f5 or queen takes h4 follow it up
by taking on f3 or bishop recapturing
your last piece and you're just simply
two pawns up and a devastating attack
against the king so you cannot do that
after queen to d2
probably black has to go knight to h7
you have two attackers against g5 i have
to find two defenders and with this move
knight to h7 you open up the queen's uh
defense as well as the knight on h7 you
found the two defenders but
my knight finally
gets to where it wants to be right right
on f5 or potentially if you do take on
g4 and say okay i messed up your pawn
structure well sure but thank you very
much
because now i have some ideas of
putting the king either to h1 maybe even
getting it to e2 and then following it
up with rook to g1 setting up the
pressure on the g5 still a very complex
middle game right now let's see what he
decides to do but i have to say this is
a critical moment in this game and just
to finish it up with the games that i've
been following in the junior section
quite a funny moment came at this point
in the game between balaji and david
brodsky
rook to c8 after knight to e5 and this
was the position that we were looking at
we said bishop to 85 queen take c5 queen
takes f2 would be the main line he
decided to go rook to c8 and from a
practical perspective i have to say i
like this move because knight to d7 is
almost a force in the position and after
bishop takes d7 you have to be very
careful because if you do take on d7
rook takes c3 boom comes on the board
and you're actually
losing your queen rook to d8 now there's
no more queen takes b5 so you resign on
the spot you have to be very careful
he did not
fall for a district he took on b6 take
on b6 rook takes d7 maybe e5 rook takes
e7 by the way is not on the board and as
you were mentioning this is exactly what
he's thinking about e5 or rook takes d7
i was afraid if i take on d7 you take on
c3
yes yes that is the question and this is
the question that i wanted to pass on to
you guys
what do you think about the position
does white have anything the engine is
saying that white has a decent advantage
decent 0.5 0.2 right now
you don't think that's the case
personally i don't think that's the case
either but
is it more than uh
we can see with the naked eye no
no no
i've made an executive decision
we're standing on yeah yeah yeah yeah
what is that all real can games are
drawn that's right that's what they say
all rook endings are drawn rook takes d7
is on the board so he decided to go for
this one yeah i don't feel that black is
really suffering in that game now it's
one of those hand games if you're forced
to choose a side right you probably
choose white the king is closer to the
pawns that are weak king and jade is far
but
are you really worried you should have
enough counter play pausing c2 are weak
eight exactly
even even e4 is targetable yeah
uh and by the way mishra did play
exactly that move that you were looking
at queen d2
and a wonder liang
pretty much played knight h7 very
quickly and we are expecting that move
knight e3 inviting black to mess up the
structure
and to get a very
awkward
uh middle game position both sides are
going to have tough time navigating this
because uh we all remember the
black winter yeah yeah the bishop h2 man
it's funny we always say that it's
actually winter company exactly we
always get it wrong uh reversed uh so
we'll keep an eye on and i think it's a
more recent one or more recent stories a
game between kramnik and nigel short
yes that had the same very sad bishop
story exactly
i wanted to jump to uh the girls
championship because uh sophie is just
she's got depressing a perfect uh what i
want to say
uh really low passes dream spanish yeah
exactly spanish the spanish torture by
the way i was looking at my uh lee chess
uh
uh
named the game and it was
joko piano here it comes
classical variation i'm thinking to
myself which in which game
i believe it was
the game of mishra and a wonder okay and
i was thinking to myself the joco pianos
500 years old
let's start there and now it's the
classical variation of the joke of yeah
i mean that's the dusty part of the
library right i mean come on i mean wow
but uh sophie looking really good when
we left it we had seen the move and you
were critical christian you're going to
play bishop b7 you're going to play
bishop c8 means that you you're wrong
footing your pieces b2b3 me like uh
keeping this knight which is really
kind of
struggling suddenly yeah it's a very
nice it's a very rare of this with b3
and i like bishop d2 as well it actually
first moved b4 which
is on which she plays on the spot this
is a great position for sophie feels she
understands the situation much better
than her opponent exactly not to mention
that
straight up for everybody that's
watching and plays this variation i i
think the chigorian variation of the
spanish is just not correct yeah there's
so many spanishes that you can play that
are popular right now right side surf to
some degree the briar
of course the marshall is what
everybody's playing
and this is what we're talking about
right here where after the move d4 the
move queen c7 is more
properly called the chicorun i've even
seen anatoly karpov
play the knight d7 and the movie before
exists as well
okay just not with the move queen c7
yeah yeah yeah i actually played that 97
bishop f6 idea a few times you did there
we go good i did and who who taught you
how to play that one christian because
it's it's always cool
yeah i think i i think me and eric
hansen we were looking for like weird
ideas no
black uh with the black pieces back when
we were in college uh and we came up
with this idea of knight d7 bishop f6
it's not great i mean in general if
white knows what to do they will
probably get an advantage okay
very nice okay again i'm still playing
some weird stuff in the real lopez i
really need to change that
i actually play with knight d7 and the
same idea but without the move c5 so
basically the same thing just without
that
yeah and i i've seen um
our friend mickey adams he kind of plays
some offbeat when he doesn't get a
chance to play as marshall right he does
some offbeat stuff i think today's game
by jennifer you is actually a very key
game it's funny that
uh the vagaries of fashion we're talking
about the slav exchange and look what
happens allen says hey wait a minute
looking across the board you're jennifer
you i'm gonna i'm gonna play very
solidly
in a um
and jennifer says i don't think so
you can take that solid and go away i'm
coming after your king i'm hunting
and maybe the style of a wonder g5 h5
let's go right i like it especially for
the tournament situation looking at it
from the first perspective yeah third
draw in a row i don't think really puts
any wins behind her sales exactly uh she
wants to start scoring points put some
pressure on sophie who's currently the
leader who already has a great position
so you look at this position and think
well
i need to start winning some games and
that's a clear indication now whether
this is sound or not right that's what i
wanted to get your insights on coaches
uh
is is this
maybe jennifer
going a little bit
too aggressive too early or
does she have good
reasons for thinking that this attack
could pan out
it's kind of borderline when you
determine whether you can throw your
pawns forward in the stuff like this
yeah there's a few things that you need
to consider first of all where is your
king going to go is it going to stay on
e8 and it's going to be safe okay it's
fine on e8 so this is for the moment for
the moment
with the knight on a4 displacing it from
the king side displacing it from the
center variations of e4 are very hard to
achieve right the knight is going to
take a couple of tempe to come back so
there are certain details in the
position this knight on a4 the the
wasted tempo on a3
that starts to give you an impression
that if there was any moment where you
can successfully throw the pawns it
would be now because of again the a2 a3
knight c3 a4 that's too tempe that may
have been better used elsewhere so that
that that actually induces you to think
in these terms but now having said that
why isn't white kind of happy because
she's got a lot and i mean a lot of
palace guards around the king she's
saying
come on do your worst go ahead play h4
go ahead play g4 well it's good i'll
take advantage i don't think there's
much of a choice if you don't play
one of the two moves here
i assume you play h4 but g4 i was kind
of worried about that
yeah maybe i'll just clip the pawn and
you're gonna have a hard time proving
yeah i don't see why you would throw
this pawn first i think you go h1
actually h4 played okay that's on the
board yeah kind of bishop h2 looks box
g4 also looks boxy i'm very worried as
black in this moment that if you are
able to move the knight from f3 to d2 e1
e5 it doesn't actually matter you never
get the move g4 exactly so let's do it
while the way yep take take you might as
well take take and now h3
is a strong threat right uh you can't
really meet h3 with g3 with the bishop
on h2 it's just too much it's not the
way you do it yeah
and remember that these girls are doing
well
well i think one the other of course
even though
even though both of these girls uh threw
away a win with the black pieces against
dallas lee uh jennifer you in the first
round oh they have that in common they'd
have that in common right wow okay
jennifer was winning on one move this
queen d5 against dallas just devastated
her opponent's position didn't find it
and alan was just winning yesterday
allowed some kind of magical
counter play rook c4 rook a4 i mean
alice had found it that rook c1 that
whole idea bad luck really i mean
sometimes you blunder and move forward
yeah rooksy one is a hard move to
consider
yeah and she just
she just chose the wrong square for her
queen yeah an undefended square she
could be two and uh
continuing our line uh bishop takes you
for i was going to drop the knight in
here yes to e5 more or less
i i think that's why
yeah take take now any trades on e5 i
was actually going to recapture with the
bishop just so you're not stuck exactly
now's the time for h3 looks like it to
me okay
now we get here and uh i start to think
because
i'm sitting there going i could play g4
to keep the king's side closed but i'm
also beginning to wonder can can i play
against your king all right let me let
me let me let me prove the the trainees
queen takes c2 yes h3 and i say so water
and i take on c6
immediately immediately okay i'm hitting
the queen so you don't i don't have any
time to play hg2 no time to do so i'm
assuming
[Applause]
wow uh what do you think of them apples
christian i'm serious i understand i i
don't know what i'm thinking of those
apples but i know what i'm thinking of
these apples
uh the game i think lugia and malnitsky
might actually not go for very long
because bishop to g4 was such a huge
mistake allowing the entry into this end
game devastating end game because
everything just comes with tempo for
white with harmony in the position in in
the pieces h3 bishop to d7 castle sure
i'm going to set up this pin on the
bishop on d7 your king is actually not
going anywhere right on c7 unfortunately
this bishop is controlling that square
you want to go back to e8 sure and then
how are you going to make the connection
between the rooks you're just so tied
down it looks horrendous right now h6 to
stop the move g5 and then capturing the
pawn on e4 makes some sense nevertheless
once again i'm doing the moves with the
tempo i'm developing my pieces bishop to
g2 once again attacking the pawn on e4 i
don't even think i want to take that
pawn on e4 what i want to do is actually
get this knight to g3 and i'm going to
take as much time as necessary because
you don't have what to do as black and
then take with the knight on e4 and
after that recapture with another knight
the second knight to try to get to d6
this is the key square that i want to
get at with one of my knights e5 bishop
to e3 rook to c8 this is the position on
the board it's move 11
and i would like to be able to say that
black is
worse but survivable no black is
completely losing at move 11. if you
open up the engine it says plus 3.1
plus 3.1 that is just an insurmountable
lead right now and with a lot of moves a
lot of easy moves knight to e2 is one of
them knight takes c4 just simply picking
up the pawn is another one of them
you're going to be a pawn down and the
initiative
is just devastating at this point
thank you for that question uh we were
laughing earlier because we're looking
at the game of ivor igor novikov against
jabal off where we were saying the four
pawns attack
take a look at the game of tell ya
that's an actual
for pawns attack
talia versus zoe and uh i know from a
few years ago i actually had a few
lessons with
talia and she showed me
some of her victories with the four
pawns attacks she likes it this is a
this is the hyper hyper hyper aggressive
way of meeting the king's indian and
after f4 castles knight f3 trust me when
i say the theory runs deeply
like very very deeply she likes to
capture in this position there's tons of
alternatives
on each and every move bishop d3
and i don't know what the current state
of theory is but the both players seem
to be playing pretty quickly to achieve
this position and for talia i mean uh
this is uh
this is a nice opportunity here for her
i but i think really because again i see
uh white's position as being a lot more
harmonious yes you do have the square d4
but once you occupy the square d4
well i'll
i'll move my king out of the way and
i'll be a very happy camper the knight
on g4
will be
uh under attack i mean i'm saying
what do you think is this uh i think
it's all theory but maybe i'm wrong i
don't know if it's all theory but it's
more or less along what you expect from
a four pawns kings indian exactly where
white is sometimes forced to take on e6
you get this weird structure in which
black has this huge hole on d4 they can
occupy right but it's sometimes
sometimes you wonder what do you do with
it right once you're there once you're
there it's not so clear on the other
hand black does have a very solid
structure even though d6 and e6 is a
little bit weak they're hard pawns to
get to right from my point of view i'm
thinking that i would like to trade the
bishops so i'll do something like knight
to d1 in order to play bishop to c3 and
just
let's put it down because you were
saying sometimes you get these really
weird structures or you know and
you get these pawns something
crazy like this
and it's a mess it's a mess and i think
that's what she likes you're right and
as long as she has this mess i think
she's gonna be happy especially against
an opponent that she feels
that she can take on exactly exactly and
the question what do you have for us
well guys what's better than a four pawn
attack five that's right a five pawn
attack and this is exactly what the
opportunity for navikov is right now we
see this move d5 for shabalov
and now what about this move e5 followed
by f4
that's a lot of pawns on the fourth and
fifth rank and it does seem like it's
giving white a tremendous initiative not
only that but tremendous space advantage
and we know how important space
advantage is in the game of chess not
only that but my attack is just flowing
at this point and you're going to have
to be very careful with how you're going
to try to attack my pawn structure my
next few moves are going to be probably
h3 followed by g4 try to open up the
king side and if i manage to do that i'm
going to be able to checkmate you this
one is really looking poorly right now
for alexander chabot of what is he doing
you cannot take on c4 by the way because
bishop takes b7 and unfortunately your
whole pawn structure is just going to be
in shambles you don't want to see that
again
the problem in the position is your
knight right if you go to h7 that's fine
i still go f4 where is the knight going
nowhere you have to go rook to e8 knight
to f8 and still you don't have an active
position for the knight if you go to e8
well where is your knight going
it doesn't seem like it has any uh
active uh squares and initiatives
potentially if you manage to get c6 open
up force me to take on d5 which i'm not
going to do by the way i'm most likely
going to close the position with the
move c5 later on i'm going to let you
spend a few more moves on potentially
going bishop to c6 it seems like to try
to force me to take on d5 or open up
the long diagonal no no no we're not
opening up anything i'm opening up on my
own terms the position on the king side
i'm going to go h3 followed by g4
it's looking really bad for black for
chabalov and we know once again he's a
player that loves to attack right where
is your attack as black you played the
king's indian but where is your attack
where is your counter play in the center
you don't get that if
he decides and potentially novikov will
understand the position well enough to
decide to go e5 block the bishop on g7
follow it up with f4 and just create an
avalanche of pawns on the king side that
position is a model
situation for
when you have an advantage in space keep
all the pieces on the board because you
see how difficult black's pieces are
when you have an advantage in space
imagine that you black could just traded
four nights off the board that's a
different situation totally then he
doesn't experience the the cramped
positioned and igor looking very very
good as we keep an eye on that game but
uh well we have it's time it's time for
our promotion of the day right we have
another uh special item from q
qboutiquesdl.com
this is our junior and junior girls polo
limited edition follows featuring the
official logos of the 2022 u.s junior
and junior girls
and they're available in navy maroon and
purple you also get the senior
championship if you well oh boy i have
to go
shopping myself the juniors and the
girls and as we go on break we asked the
juniors we interviewed them and said
how do you like playing in st louis
we'll see on the other side of the break
how does it feel to once again be back
in st louis playing in this prestigious
event it feels great this is my sixth
time playing so
i think from the first time i've played
to now you know i've seen a lot of
players come and go and a lot of players
still here so
yeah it's definitely very special
as a feeling just have gone from one of
the youngest players in the event to
think that i'm the oldest player in the
event so
there's a there's a lot of history for
me and a lot of um great feelings and
you know obviously it's always great
just to be back in st louis feels great
this is my first time playing this
tournament and it's a really strong
event and i think it's a great
opportunity for me to get some
experience against all these great
players i'm glad to be back last time i
was here
um was in october so it's been a while
but yeah very exciting i actually
haven't played juniors in a while now
it's a little bit weird i guess i'm not
playing the girls section like i usually
am
but i'm very excited for this tournament
i'm really excited to be here and it's
my last time so i want it
and and on a high note it feels really
nice it's it's a tournament i've been
waiting for and it's a strong field and
i
will look forward to playing
definitely very excited
it's quite a
big tournament obviously
and very excited to play all my you know
fellow
competitors it feels amazing st louis is
one of the many places i look forward to
coming back to recently i had this
amazing i had these amazing events one
was a the spring classic group we wish i
won it feels amazing to be back here i
hope my streak continues generally enjoy
enjoy playing at the st louis chess club
for for several tournaments so
it is always nice to
be here be
here and play play tournaments in st
louis chess club um it's a great honor
president great honor and pleasure to be
back in um
my first time was actually last year so
this time just you know trying to do my
best
and hopefully improve upon last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are here round
three off a nice trio of championships
in st louis let's start with the
pairings of round three from the junior
girls as we have every game still on
board we think that our two most
important matchups here are ellen wang
with the white pieces playing against
jennifer yu in what it has become a
fascinating exchange slot not words that
are usually put together right and
sophie mori suzuki that has a brilliant
relopez position against a gracie
prasanna we'd like also talia's uh four
palms attack against today and in the
juniors in the juniors we have great
games but the one that's captivating us
is the duel of grandmasters between
abhimanyu mishra and a wonderlianga so
you have a very fun italian type of
position but remember that crucial for
the standings is the game between justin
wang with one and a half points playing
against
uh andrew hong with two and then the
game between carissa yep we saw
the exchange sacrifice uh that we
expected that's an exciting game and in
the seniors in the senior section we
have a bunch of interesting games
christians in the fermi and certainly
the interesting one but we have had our
eyes on the game between maxine delugi
and igor kavlinicki because we feel that
maxim already has a decisive advantage
that's exactly right
bad opening choice there with bishop g4
um by igor and he's
it's a struggle just to survive at this
point yes he has lost the e4 pawn i like
very much what christian was saying that
you know what you just go nine
two
with patience exactly
knight to eve
g3 and you want to land with your knight
on e4 thanks to the square d6 but max
said you know what i'm very happy
putting my knight on f3 i'm pressing
pressing against the pawn on e5 i'll
move my rook i'll take on c6 i'll take
on e5 i'll be happy whenever i can
induce the move f6 then i'm ready to
pounce in either case i really
really don't like what i'm seeing on
eagle side of the board just
no no no no and by the way you're upon
down
just by the way and by the way just by
the way you know that's not a good uh
it's not good it's not good that's not
the survivors by the way g7 g6 on the
board
i played already that
the idea behind uh that was because
there was a possibility of check and
takes and also once again takes on c6
and takes on e5 so the idea of defending
the um pawn on g6 with the move bishop
g7 made sense g6 i'm expecting bishop g7
but
max is uh max is in his element right
here right now yeah absolutely uh
another game that was interesting for us
in the seniors was this game we had this
one between larry christian and nick
defermin a little bit of a quieter
approach yeah lots of moves have been
happened since e2 e3 uh turned into one
of those isolated queen pond positions
where black
plays for the dynamic play and we're
caught up with the players
and i'm expecting larry to play the move
knight f3 making room for his knight to
come
from b5 to d4 on a good day the bishop
goes to b2 and roars its approval down
uh the long diagonal we'll keep our eye
on this one
and i wanted to see the game of
alexander igor novikov
i haven't it's been a while
since i've seen
so much space from one side
uh versus the other but somehow i don't
know e5 knight h7
c5
i'm i'm i must say i'm a little so i'm
shocked by the move h4 i would never
have played h4 myself i really like that
idea that christian was suggesting that
you know you can castle and then you
slowly slowly prepare your break with
h3g4 he went h4
f6
and we're caught up it's a better
version for black no matter what happens
almost because
f takes e5 is actually kind of annoying
you're not going to be able to castle
easily as white you would sometimes
think about castle in queenside but you
already moved that rook right the rook
is on b1 it's already on b1 and if i
don't have access to the f file
yeah i mean i will consider taking on e3
i know that it's a nice knight and this
is not the best bishop right but you
lack so much space as black that you
kind of want to take some pieces off the
board truly you know let's let's trade
oh so
shabba
fighting his way out of a significant
space disadvantage and uh over to you
christian what has caught your eye well
uh i'm having my eyes on the juniors
section because things are definitely
heating up and let's take a look at what
happened first of all in the game
between karissa and brandon jacobson
because
we mentioned that after f takes e4 d
takes e4 rook takes f3 which in fact
came on the board this is the best
version that black can get
karissa decided not to take the exchange
not to accept the sacrifice and actually
take on g4 first and now we see rook to
f8 knight to e3 and queen to h4 but
we're starting to look at the position
and it is quite obvious who has the
advantage who has the initiative and who
is dictating what's happening in the
position and it is not white because
right now this pawn on g4 first of all
you have to defend it somehow and it
does seem like the only way to defend it
and to uh maintain the material balance
is to play the move f3 but this is not
something that you want to see with this
monster on the a7 g1 diagonal good luck
getting out of this pin because king to
f1 that's almost a checkmate after queen
to h1 you don't want to see that on the
board king to h1 the h file is
unfortunately uncovered right now
because you took on g4 with uh the pawn
from h3 so i have carte blanche on what
i'm going to do the next few moves right
now knight to d8 is one of them knight
to e7 is one of them i have so many ways
in which i can improve my position and
it's very easy to understand what you
have to do as black because you look at
the pieces everything is playing an
active role right except potentially the
knight on c6 and this is a very typical
maneuver in these type of positions you
get this knight either to uh from d8 to
e6 or f7 to g5 or f4 getting closer to
the king or you can just simply go
knight to e7 like to g6 knight to f4 get
it closer to the king it's very obvious
that right now it is karissa who is
well she has to be very careful not to
get checkmated and not to allow this
knight to get closer to her king because
there's going to be too many forces that
she will have to deal with it's
definitely looking like brandon jacobson
is in full control in this one and let's
take a look at what's happening
in this game guys or better yet what's
not happening in this game
the game between barachi dagupati and
david brosky david has been thinking
after rook takes d7 for the past
if my math is correct close to 40
minutes wow here what is he thinking
about what is he thinking about because
if you don't take the knight on c3 then
you're in a completely losing position
right clearly right you have to take
your pawn back either we're having some
sort of a transmission issue either i'm
not 100 sure he fell asleep he i i don't
know what happened so we're going to
find the answer that in just a second
let's take a closer look at what's
happening in the abbey monument i'm
going to leave you with a menu of
options of which game to choose and uh
get a deeper understanding of what the
plans are because
this one knight to e3 king to h8 knight
to f5 we were looking at this maneuver
we said that abimani should probably
allow this bishop takes f3 g takes f3
and we have this position right now
queen to f6 bishop to d5
is in the game and
i'm looking at the position i like white
i i really like white i mean knight e7
does seem to be the best move in the
position now doesn't this just allow me
to pick up a pawn potentially after
knight takes c7 and bishop takes b7 is
this bad
perhaps it is perhaps it is because
right now it does seem like
maybe black is getting a lot of
initiative on this side right in the
absence of the knight on f5 so
bishop to d5 it does seem like it's a
little bit of an inaccuracy uh by abby
money better would have been rook to d1
or just simply queen to e2 or maybe just
try to open up the position with the
move d4 not only open up the position
but also put more pressure on e5 and
make it more difficult for the knight on
c6 to remaneuver to a better square this
is the key uh aspect in this position he
played the move bishop to d5 is going to
be a very complex battle take it away
guys and go to whichever game you would
like let's jump into the sophie
morris game
against gracie
uh this was the really really nice rui
lopez game that we like for white now
sophie
actually played
i want to say the most straightforward
uh line a b a b rook a8 knight a bishop
d3 and yes i do like her position after
rook a1 i think white is for choice
space etc etc but i do remember
uh looking at a lot of these soviet
championship games it's like the soviet
the soviet championships were monstrous
affairs like 20 players single round
robin that lasted for 40 days and the
best players of the world would play
these and i remember these games where
the soviet players
would uh
invite the knight to this wonderful
square c4 right here right and then
that's it that's it you have no more
play you would play like let's say the
move bishop d7 i would play the move
rook a2 you would play the move rook c8
and you could do nothing in the club
yeah on the queen side right and then
comes knight h2 queen f3 and how many
times did i see these attacks crash
through queen f3 and it was almost like
play on one goal
because the
the
center was shot
the queen side was shut and black had no
active counter play yeah the weird part
of this is that even though the knight
on c4 is beautiful it really is it it's
in the way it blocks this blocks
right you can't move it you know exactly
you never get access to a3 b2 d2 or e3
right and you're permanently stuck
outside of d6 and e5 because of the
right
exactly out of a5 because of b4 and of
b6 right because of a5 right so you're
stuck you're completely dead stuck on c4
for the rest of the game and then like i
said it was a very uh positional
sophisticated positional
play by white where they would play
knight h2 queen f3 knight g4 and i stood
in awe as a teen playing through
these giants of the soviet chess world
and what sofia has done is gotten
a nice um i want to say space edge
but
is it a big advantage well we'll keep an
eye on that and i also wanted to jump to
the jennifer you game because that was
the game where jennifer was going
i attack i attack i attack has she
succeeded aleandra i like this move
knight d2 actually we were looking at
the move knight e5 i think we were yes
but knight tito makes a similar sense
right you want to cover some of your
light squares allow some pieces to the
king side okay so 92 makes sense i want
to trade i want to trade and i'm
actually a little bit surprised
no bishop my fire looks normal okay but
after bishop g4 did you have to take
this bishop no i would i would think if
i'm in jennifer's shoes i want to keep
pieces on the board maybe maybe even
bishop d3 exactly just to try to throw
a little monkey wrench in the works
there
she did take which by the way bishop d3
was still following a game before no
georgiev kirito and zucchin
yes so former women's world champion
from china but it's so impressive by the
way ellen wang her rating is around
2040.
and she's following up without knowing
about that game because she's spending a
lot of time she's 40. i think so and
she's following the game of a 2661
feeder rating kyogre of kirill she's
playing really good moves right now i'm
mightily impressed with the way she's
handling herself 24. it seems very
underrated
and here uh
a little uh a little uh what do you
profile thank you
what took you so long
you got a cover for me dude 14. 14 so
young uh only one year older than ellis
lee actually two-time north american
junior girls champion an invitational
rating of 22-13 which means
right there north american junior girls
we're talking
cat canadian yeah in america and mexico
canada america mexico yes yeah it was
that sounds like a very nice competition
she's won it twice she's won it twice
it's actually a very strong competition
i think last year was won
by annie wang
like what because it's a super strong
event wow okay uh bishop g4 i take
what do you think about this uh i'm not
i'm not a huge fan for black the thing
is that if i stick my queen on age three
it's a bit uncomfortable i get it but i
just stop but you stopped the counter
play and by the way the queen kind of
covers a lot of pretty important squares
it's not bad yeah all i want to do is
play knight to c5 and ellen
could easily take the initiative and
that's such a case yeah we were talking
earlier about what do you do with your
king
and
it's a it's a permanent problem for
jennifer
the moment that the center blows up you
can imagine it blowing up with a move
like e4 at some point down the road sure
um that king only 8 is going to be
vulnerable whereas i don't see
how you connect the rooks in order to
attack g2 right this rook has to make a
magic leap to g8 this knight has to go
here and even after you get in a number
of attacking moves for black still not
sure that jennifer is going to land with
something maybe i have to play knight h7
to g5 we'll keep our eye on this one uh
two games that uh
one game in particular we have not seen
i wanted to jump to it was rue yang yan
against alice lee alice has kind of been
fortunate yes i mean yeah she could
easily
yeah two y's and she could have scored
zero out of two on those and she made
two draws and today she gets black uh
for the first time
and let's see what we've got on the
board it looks like some kind of reverse
sicilian
right
look i'm not going to name the baby here
you know reverse the silhouette i meant
the structure yeah the structure is uh
sicilian-esque
okay what's your first impression i like
black
seriously if i could play knight c5
and plant tonight on this
wonderful
wonderful d4 square i'd be happy
i like the king in the center and the
ending
um and it's not that easy for white like
where are you go are you supposed to go
bishop g4 i would have are you supposed
to go d4 i think i'll go king to e3
maybe a rook to f1 i'm not actually very
fond of this move f4 that was played
earlier earlier i don't like trading the
dark squared bishops ah you mean right
about these parts yeah i i don't like f4
in general like the whole concept of
rook f104 i thought was a bit
unnecessary
castles is kind of normal or whatever i
don't think you can castle
have i made an illegal move by castle
yeah king d1 and e1 was already played i
apologize i can't see the earlier party
but even if you could i like the king in
the center so often this king is fine on
e3
knight b3 knight c4 or something like
that yeah you're thinking you wanted to
bring the king to e3 yes do this king e3
when i'm right he'll play now
that yeah now that
clarifies everything for me and i like
this picture that you're painting put
the king on e3 put the pawn on d4 and
slowly slowly build
a space advantage the current position i
think is
slightly better for black i like it
because uh uh pawn islands palm airlines
you have three pawn islands that's white
yep and black has two sometimes it's as
simple as that that says positions
lazy man's stress but it works i
remember i
i had lost a game to vladimir kramnik
and i was having breakfast with gary
gary caspar off and i was like uh
how did you sleep terrible what what did
you do
it wasn't good
gary what did i do wrong
yesterday my game with vladimir and he
said and i quote
two bishops
you know
eating your moose
you just stop you know it's as simple as
that you know vladimir had the two
bishops and that's what
yeah yeah
sometimes chess isn't that hard i'm i'm
i'm going to break your bubble
do it christian white white is much
better in this book
plus one no no
get out of here with a lot of moves get
it on your own watch anything that you
play kingdom get him an engine that
agrees with us
so i think it's called alpha zero yeah
right here
but it's quite interesting because with
the naked eye i was looking at the
position before i turned on the engine
and i was thinking the same i was like
okay it does seem like i have a
healthier pawn structure i have this
knight coming to c5 pressure on d3 later
on after i double up or i just simply
put a rook on d8 right it just feels
like black is slightly better and i'm
going to be able to secure your pressure
against your pressure on the f-file
which just simply bishop to e6 right and
that's going to defend
my pawn on f7
unfortunately it doesn't seem like it's
that easy because this knight from c4 uh
it looks innocuous right now but i am
going to jump to a5 that's the fish rask
knight on a5 for example if you go
knight to c5 i can go knight to a5 right
now how do you continue right right
that's one of the moves i can just start
with rook to f1 force almost forced the
bishop to come to come to uh e6 and then
go knight to a5 again i'm setting up
traps i'm setting up problems for your
position and if you do i defend on b7
because i was threatening b4 kick the
knight away and then take on b7 i will
continue kicking the knight away not
only that but then now we understand
that my pawn majority in the center can
actually be used to make your pieces
feel uncomfortable bishop to g4 is one
of the moves but i can also start with
d4 once again we're coming back to the
idea of taking center
excuse me taking space away from black's
pieces so i really like what's happening
in this position and a lot of things
actually have happened by the way in the
junior section um he did take he did
take on c3 i think thankfully
thankfully it did once it became
saturday i'm getting worried at some
point you think
long thing long thing wrong thing 40
minutes you also wonder what on earth he
was thinking about for 40 minutes my
guess is that he was just trying to look
at
rook c5 but i mean you are a pawn now
you're up on down you can't allow why
would you do that somewhere why would
you do that so we have this position
right now it still feels like white is
slightly better nevertheless
it's within margins yeah we made it we
made an executive decision about it
yes this one is going to be a draw but
let's take a look at what's happening
in the game between which one i wanted
to see this one again igor novikov and
in fact let's start with this one
because a lot of things have happened
okay the game between vladimir akopian
and dmitry guriovich and we haven't
looked at this one in a while right why
is there a bishop on it
that was my first question as well how
did that bishop get it
actually it was
after this position we got to uh with
the knighthood b4
and a3 and knight way to knight a2
exchange on a to exchange the queens and
unfortunately you don't have time to
trap this bishop because uh bishop to b2
is going to come and then you're
actually in some sort of
trouble also i have a feeling bishop
takes b3 might come on the board at some
point so you cannot play the move b3 but
what if you just simply develop aren't
you just a pawn up at this point
develop bishop to e2 get ready to put
the bishop place the bishop on a better
square that is the square f3 a
tremendous square because i'm attacking
pawn on b7 creating a lot of uh
unpleasant trees in your position what
do you do as black
two bishops that's two bishop two
bishops and the problem is that if you
try to go a bishop to the c5 c7 issue
that's a problem exactly that is a
problem but perhaps even rook takes d5
right could be a question and then
knight to c7 and then we get into this
end game and which results sure thank
you very much we'll play this for 100
moves right um obstacle our bishops pawn
up to results
i'm very happy with the outcome of the
opening and it seems like vladimir
akopian is once again getting a better
position in this sharp sicilians
stop playing this against vladimir
because he's going to get you let's see
if he manages to cover
this one
we have been warned i wanted to turn our
attention to talia's game because
anybody who plays a four pawns attack uh
deserves respect uh we left it after
bishop d2 b6 queenie two queen e7 i was
uh expecting tell you to bring her rook
into play she played knight g5
immediately and i think she said
a little bit of a trap here for zoe
zoe said you know i love the square d4
and i'm gonna plant my bishop on d4
check and i think this was wrong i think
she had to
just swallow her pride and maybe move
back with the knight after bishop d4
check talia has basically said hahaha
i've tricked you
i've got you to play bishop g7
to d4 and maybe at a certain moment i'm
going to take
this dark square bishop off the board
and you're going to be feeling you know
very regretful that you gave up
the dark swears and after
bishop to b7 rook e1 we've caught up
with the players
uh talia doesn't have to take this right
away it's not like it's going anywhere
at the moment and i think a6 played
a6 what do you think did she set a nice
little cunning trap there for our
opponent
i feel it changes the character of the
position but i don't think that black
should mind
that much the thing is that sometimes
this bishop on g7 even though it's a
good defender yes it is a bit passive in
positions where you follow up with move
e5 yeah well then it's looking at a
closed close diagonal and yeah okay so
let's take over for talia for a moment
i'm going to like we need to why do i
queen e2 d1 why because i'm anticipating
when i do capture this
i don't want the knight to recapture
with the tempo
but oops excuse me but the other thing
is i'm kind of sliding towards the idea
of knight c3 to e2 in order to make sure
a piece doesn't end up on d4 sorry i
think this is a clear example of the
thread being stronger than the execution
right you take on d4 the knight comes to
d4 the relaxed pieces the bishop on b7
looks good right this threat's not going
away you can take on d4 pretty much any
time no i'm i was about to say do i also
have a hidden thread of knight d5 it's a
move not sure it threatens too much
probably not yeah but okay uh definitely
we're keeping a eye out on this game
once again i'm just going to check in on
jennifer you our top tournament seat and
we've seen the movie we're saying
ellen is playing great i still dislike
jennifer's position i think that i
feeling it as well yeah this bishop
takes g4 move i think we both did not
like
and
black has thrown her king side forward
and she hasn't asked answered the saline
question jennifer what are you going to
do with your
king which is sitting on
in the center of the board all right and
back over to you christian as we just go
through some of the seniors games
uh over here absolutely while i was uh
looking at what happened in the carissa
and brandon jacobson and actually a lot
of things have happened let's take a
look so
after the move um i think this is where
we left it off and yeah it was scouting
knight d8 knight to e7 i2e7 was played
by brandon jacobson followed by queen to
e1 i like this move by carissa trying to
simplify the position
the dream for white is to exchange the
queens right
then you're
finally going to be able to go king to
f1 knight to f5 and have
a perfect position probably or just
simply better nice structure at that
point so queen 21 queen to g5
sidestepping the trade of the queens
very good decision by brandon and now we
have rook two f to it and now comes the
question what is carissa thinking about
is she potentially hinting at an
exchange sacrifice with knight to d5 i
think that might actually be a threat so
you start
uh asking yourself how do you parry
knight to d5 for example if you go i'm
just going to make a random move on the
board
knight to d5 is one option but i also
have knight to f5 you're having some
difficulties right
you can take on f2 queen takes f2 but
then where do you put the queen queen to
f6 defending the knight sure g5 i'm
going to follow up i'm gaining the
initiative not only that but you just
simply don't have any squares for the
queen so you're in trouble rook to f2
this might have been a move that was
missed
by brandon jacobson because right now
you have to start dancing with the queen
around and
it doesn't feel like you're improving
the position especially in the last few
moves you haven't improved your position
white wild white has been gaining more
and more control over the security of
their own king this is what i'm seeing
right now from these two players and
queen to f6 is in fact on the board
queen f6 what a strange move he just
played queen g5 exactly
yeah it feels like uh
logic glitch it feels like he's getting
a little bit outplayed right right the
last few moves especially because if
white gets in a very desirable move i
don't know if i can play it right now
but if i could play the move g3
king g2 g2 get off that diagonal off
that diagonal line stopping knight g6 f4
it covers the dark squares which is a
big problem oh that's a great move geez
i like it i feel that black player is
doing fine
not only fine but maybe slowly but
surely we'll start gaining the
initiative exactly
exactly i like g3 in in the seniors just
one second yes sir before we move back
to the seniors there is another uh
slight development if you want to put it
that way in the game of our leader
andrew hung versus justin wang and we
have this position right now the last
move was rook to c2 we started off at
the beginning saw this end game and
thought that none of the players are
probably going to create any
difficulties for the counterparty so
right now after rook to c2 it does feel
like if andrew finds this move knight to
c7
a great move the idea is obviously to go
knight to b5 jump to d4 attack in the
process the pawn on a3 as well create
problems for your opponent if he finds
this move knight to c7 yeah it's
starting to look really good for black
and very difficult and unpleasant to
defend this for the white side so knight
to c7 a big moment could potentially
become a critical moment as well of the
game because if you do play the natural
move a4 defense against knight to b5 i
go back thank you very much now i get
this
a very important square from which i can
cause problems the square b4 and you're
in trouble
this is a huge game for both of these
players because let's not forget justin
wang started with a bang against a
wonder liang with the white pieces took
down the rating favorite going into this
event and andrew hung so far has been
unstoppable with two out of two um
it seemed to me christian in that
position where justin played the move
rooksy two he's lost the thread
of the position the problem for white's
position
uh well let me just bring it up uh oh
you have it yes was rook c2 was just
wrong the problem in white's position is
the rook on h1 and i understand you
don't want to castle and potentially
leave the knight on d2 high and dry but
if you take the move rook c1 back
there's more than one way to develop
your rook yes
h4 h5 wow rook h4 and rook a4
uh yeah this looks if i could get in our
edition so let's try to go knight to b6
and maybe this was the main plan for
black up to that point because i do want
to play c4 i want to simplify the
position right exchange everything if
you do go h5 i will continue with c4
b4 cc
[Music]
i know is it sure is it a liability or
no
it's an asset it is definitely necessary
right now yes yes yes because knight b3
we're just following i can just simply
go either knight a4 or just simply
bishop to b5 what bishop b5 yes rook h4
rook to h4 good move and let's go start
attacking your pawns
your weaknesses in the position because
you haven't i was bringing my rook into
play alejandro why i'm saying it's it's
it's uh not a liability but an asset is
that it also supports this knight to d2
move
questions
it is what it is
christmas presents for you
no postcards no bouquet of flowers no
chocolates either you're a bad boy yeah
yeah
no i mean it looks good
not
nothing has happened right now i mean
white is not losing no no no potentially
not even worse after knight to c7 but
it's on he's on the back okay he's
defending he's the one defending right
right now he's the one parrying threats
at every single move and generally you
don't want to see that you started off
with the white
pieces you got a slight edge in the end
game but you did not expect to get
outplayed right and this is slowly
what's happening right now andrew hung
if he wins this one with black pieces
wow against uh justin wang who's no
pushover right not at all yeah you can
ask for wonder uh i wanted to say that
max
delugey uh is cruising he's actually
ended up winning
another pawn so he's two pawns up in his
game with igor
that game is all but over for the
shouting yeah
too much too much i wanted to also check
in with joel benjamin
and uh gregory sorry to say that yeah
white's for choice
he's got
more
control
it's a pull but
let's face it
it's not thrilling no no it's not really
nice it's also very close to actual
equality exactly now uh in the uh
the california matchup
uh knight back to after bishop g4 that's
a little bit of a surprise knight jumped
back to d4 i was expecting something
like this knight
coming maybe larry is a
larry of queen f6 not sure he played
knight f3 to d4 trade
and normally speaking trades
anything like this would i'm assuming be
a dream for larry because well at the
end of the day you have an isolated
queen pawn and no pieces to attack with
of course i understand
the c3 square but you think it's even i
don't think this is even this looks much
better for white oh good good good good
good
it's working it's working
uh
wow uh like this has become a mess such
a strange bone structure
he played bishop b5 and igor said i
don't want to see this bishop land on c4
but he opened up the half open a file
and
i don't know where somehow with each pet
every time i look at this position
somehow i think shabba has improved and
it's still worse
it was so bad
you're looking at every five minutes
it's improved every five minutes and
it's still bad
no but this is actually a
position where you can think as black
that you have some resources this night
on h7 finds a useful plan and i would
think black is already for choice but
there's no use for a platform
that is a problem that's a big if let's
say
i do crazy something horrible yeah i
play knight to g1 with the idea like i
want to recapture with the d-pawn okay
and kind of keep your pieces
knotted up let's let's leave it at that
and knight f3 is on my agenda he played
bishop h3
and i like that move i mean the bishop
really didn't have
um
what i would say the most useful life on
g2 diagonal bishop h3 could be a little
awkward and maybe encourage
takes and kind of freezes this knight
from moving e6 is
um
it still feels like igor's for choice
and once again he is a tournament
co-leader along with larry christensen
in this the third round funny enough he
actually played the best moves in the
last few moves
uh
again visually doesn't igor that is yes
visually it doesn't feel like he
improved his position but in fact he did
improve his position okay
okay all right well nice game huh
nice to know and uh what is going on
with the
i want to say the the carissa yet came
right yeah the cursor came back it's
actually fascinating i'm trying to
understand why
brandon's stutter step
exactly thank you f6 he could have gone
i don't know why exactly the queen is on
f6 but if he wanted the queen on f6
he could have played it in one move and
i'm wondering it was for me i actually
crazily enough i thought that you wanted
to keep contact with this knight and go
queenie why do i want a queen h6
specifically because i was afraid of
this
ideas like the worst thing i could
imagine is g3 king g2 yeah then i've got
nothing on the king side right and i
cannot play g3 as long as the pawn on f3
is hanging right now you may be thinking
oh that's terrible i'm sorry stepping
into a potential discovery well not so
fast you're not going anywhere that
night is pinned and i'm dreaming
i'm dreaming of dropping the knight in
he played the move queen g5 what what is
the difference between queen g5 and
queen h6 if i reply with the same move
sorry which moves rook f2 as carissa did
in the game rook f2 can i jump in
or does that thing i don't think you can
play that i'm
i think it was the queen
exactly it's a double attack right
double attack i was going to put my
knight on f4 very ah
no no no no just a second just a second
can i
well if i go queen h4 you could go
rook out
right yeah huh okay uh fair enough she
played
pardon me
brandon uh played queen g5 rook f2 queen
f6
and
so
is there any merit right now and is
karissa actually thinking about
sacrificing an exchange with knight d
knight f5
i think it's g3 related isn't it yeah
there's some merit to it but why right
you can play knight five when it doesn't
cost you
exchange probably a good question right
i think i will take it are you taking
with the e pawn or the g bomb with the g
pawn because i want to get the other uh
pawn from g2 to g4
okay so aha so you're ready to meet g6
with gg4 yes that was my make sense
it's one of those positions where i feel
white definitely has compensation but
i'm also asking myself why do i have
compensation why don't i play normal
moves exactly yeah uh it's intriguing
it's intriguing uh
i like g3 no yeah three is definitely
yeah yeah yeah this is the move that
once you see g there was a game from the
candidates and i want to say it was duda
versus fabi
where duda was on the white side and he
arranged his king side at a knight on f3
and knight on h2k and we played g three
g3 and then
he's attacked
just hit a brick wall right and
dude messed it up but then he righted
the ship and he won a fantastic game so
g3
king g2
rook f1
move the knight yeah
and put the knight on f5 for carissa and
i think with all of that maneuvering she
will end up with a better structure and
by the way the better minor pieces too
because i like this bishop
on c4 and e and c1 well we'll keep an
eye on that yeah what else is called
well guys let's take this is the joke of
pianos right so let's move uh yeah fair
enough where do we go i wonder to the
abbey money versus a wonder game because
it does feel uh with the last few moves
that the wonder is slowly taking over
okay with black pieces and this is the
position we have right now after bishop
to d5 which i think it was a misstep
right knight to e7 did come on the board
and now probably white realized that
oops if you take on b7 you're probably
going to give me way too much initiative
way too much speed with which my pieces
are going to come towards your king so
once again i take c7 which was in fact
played if you do continue taking on b7
rook to b8 followed by f5 queen to f6
a lot of things are going to happen on a
df file and you also have the b2 pawn to
worry about you don't want to be in this
position for only one pawn so
what he did was take only seven queen
takes e7 and play the move at d4 but now
unfortunately this bishop on d5 it's no
longer an asset no longer a beautiful
central piece but rather a liability
because everything comes with temple and
c6 came with temple bishop to c4 and
bishop takes f3 this is currently the
position we have right now
the more i look at this and with the
exclusion of the knights right now
i'm starting to be really worried about
exactly on h2 because exactly i can go
f6 next move
where is this bishop going guys exactly
where is your attack that was so
beautifully uh
orchestrated a couple of moves ago right
it's not looking good it's not looking
healthy from a strategical point of view
if your bishop on h2 gets stuck here
you're in big trouble
i couldn't agree with you more i mean
that bishop on h2 uh it's uh is is in
terror like oh my gosh i could be
trapped and i could never get in
i mean you you start to think i should
play f4 yeah this is the story i
put my bishop back on g1 but i'm not
speaking foreign
exactly strategically winning right and
then they just leave it and they leave
it at that right yeah like figure it out
yourself i'm actually kind of curious
christian
i my instinct is this is minus one
territory for black
what do you think
okay just a second before you get in
christian right i was gonna say i really
don't like white position at all
but i don't know if it's minus one just
yet so i'll go
minus oh zero zero yeah yeah yeah zero
zero zero zero
after f6 is zero zero zero zero i don't
know why don't they ask me because i
look at the bishop and i'm like i'm
playing with that zero how could it be
zero
zero zero i'm playing with an extra
piece
right
what why is it zero zero i i have no
idea i
i don't know anything lots of words i
guess what it's trying to say the engine
is that i have some sort of a blockade
in the position and there's no way for
you to improve your position without
allowing my bishop to get back into
place so for example f5 is not a break
because the pawn on e5 is going to be a
problem
maybe you just don't see if you do
maneuver your knight to g6 and put it on
f4 then at least i can get uh my bishop
and exchange it for that knight on f4 so
i guess what the engine is recommended
is just to sit and wait and not do
anything what is the return policy very
difficult very difficult to do from a
practical perspective i think it's a
free download by the way
right well as we get prepared for a
break here we just want to remind
everybody that we really do appreciate
your questions
uh i love the one about uh you know the
junior
stories because they're just so good and
this is how you can ask the commentators
as we have uh done on the past just join
us here with your questions we're
looking for them on twitch we're looking
at them on youtube we're also on
instagram and facebook and on twitter we
are at
st louis just by still chess club or
us chess champs
and let's just sneak in uh one of the
social media questions before the break
and here it is
this one might be even you might not
hear me say this very often but this
might be before yasser's time well
frank and i go way
back
frank j marshall the usda
interesting stories about fj marshall
i don't know what the j stands for right
for us james marshall but the marshall
chess club of course of new york city
down in um
what do they call it the east village
i guess so on 10th street very very very
famous
uh
what grand which greenwich greenwich
graduates
yeah yeah uh a very very famous chess
devon i think they called it at one time
but the frank marshall chess club has
just seen everybody go through the doors
and frank marshall was many times u.s
champion because they didn't organize
many u.s
so they said well who's the best player
this is way before ratings uh who's the
best player in the united states they
would say frank marshall and frank
marshall
was really famous
as a
tactician he loved uh combinative play
and i think the most famous story
was the marshall gambit and how it came
into being and the idea was that frank
marshall
he was just a chess lover no other way
of putting it and he would go to bed at
night with a notebook and a pencil
because he oftentimes woke up in the
morning dreamt about chess
and
would write
notes
on the
notebook that he kept near his bed
anyway he had conceived the marshall
gambit
in the
[Music]
he had conceived at the marshall gambit
and he was thinking who did he want to
play it against and he played this match
against a very very young
jose raul capoblanca which he had
famously lost when he was the
prohibitive favorite so he frank
marshall wanted to spring
his opening novelty
against cappa blanca and he waited eight
years to do it
now just think about that just think you
know like he's waiting
to ensnare his opponent
eight years that's delayed gratification
yeah you got it my goodness
and
over the board
capablanca refuted
his play it was really one of the most
incredible i mean you're waiting eight
years
and you end up losing
the crazy part of the story was that
marshall's idea of knight f6 bishop d6
and knight g4 was wrong today they think
the knight should stay on d5 play c7 c6
and the whole martial gambit today is
considered one of the best
gambits for black in modern therapy yeah
it still holds up it's still played at
the world championship level so frank
marshall
also kind of funny because it's one of
the few names that has not won but two
gambits associated to it the triangle
system where they go d4 d5 c4 e6 knight
c3 c6
e4 right at least i also know this as
the marshall
gambit of the triangle system yeah i
think the marshall also has
like uh it's a wing gambit i think but
marshall also in the sicilians
has a martial gambit yeah and prominent
exactly exactly thank you for the
question we're going to see you on the
other side of the brick
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefit
this area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
chess club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the us and world chess halls
of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everybody we are back in round
three of our national championships we
have the juniors the junior girls and
the seniors all playing for the maximum
title here in america we're
here in our studio in st louis let's
take a look around the horn at what's
going on in our sections we have no
games done just yet in today's round
which is kind of surprising
always in these tournaments you have a
jockeying for tournament position and
somebody with the white pieces forces
some kind of a repetition early on and
we get an early no that's not been the
case in any of our three rounds as a lot
of fighting uh taking place as we see
their view of the new i want to say
playing hall
at the saint louis chess club i just
want to jump into the game of carissa
yip as we get started with the brandon
jacobson
and when we left it yes after this move
queen f6 i think carissa just made a
really
just the perfect move g3 ready to play
king g2 she's protecting all the squares
in front of her king very hard for
for black to do anything
you get the rook uh back to f1 you clear
this diagonal
so that you can one day jump to f5 and
guess what bishop e6 bishop d3
d5 and i thought kinji through automatic
automatic move it was very strange to us
that carissa actually
captured g5 yeah perhaps because you're
looking at bishop takes f3
there's not a lot of options i think
she's planning to sacrifice next gen
there we go knight takes d5 on the board
you got to recapture the queen you don't
want to
you don't want to f3 to fall with jack
and i can imagine that okay she's happy
with bishop e4
let's just make a move for a moment i
can't imagine that she got here in her
mind she had this picture she said this
bishop is terrific
i'm going to go king g2 i'm going to
play bishop d2 i'm going to play rook h1
i'm doing great
the question is did she make a good
judgment there uh aleandra your fault
excuse me your thoughts
i feel that white's position plays
itself it's going to be depending on
whether black can get in some counter
play
of of their own of his own whether it be
on the d file whether it be on the f
file because this bishop is pretty
monstrous on
e4 looking everywhere and by the way
protecting a very important pawn yeah it
is quite a bishop that being said let's
start in our lives a little more
specifically right because after bishop
e4 yeah you're defending this knight but
c6 is not really necessary you can't
even start with a move like r8d8
just so that on bishop d2 let's make the
pretense that at some point i have
night somewhere
right yeah
but the one thing i want to avoid is i
don't want to see
i don't know i don't want to see your
uh how do you say i don't want to see
uh
the knight coming to f6 queen g yeah
queen f6 did b6 knight
uh so hold on uh rook d8 okay yes
so
i
think i want to keep queens let me play
a5
i want to play g5 on my next turn
um i'll move my queen i think i play on
t6 okay
cool
so i'm trying to i'm trying to
channel my inner charissa
i want to play obviously uh king g2
bishop out somewhere right wherever it
is
and then rook h1 that's it that's all
i'm about
we're trying to christian we we're we're
struggling
we
obviously this compensation we've got
the two bishops and a bishop it has to
be but but how much how much is it
not that much not that much just minus
1.4 it seems like right now but the more
i look at the position 1.4 sounds like a
lot but from a practical perspective
it's not that easy and you have ways to
go wrong like for example even right now
bishop to f2 is not the only move you
can just start with knight takes d5 if
you want right sure because you're still
taking the arrogant f2 the problem is
that after knight to d5 i actually have
this very nice move queen to e4
and after bishop takes f2 not king takes
f2 because after king takes f2 you have
queen to b6 followed by knight to f6
but rather king to g2 whoa
and now you're basically forced to
actually take on f3
which leads to a completely different
position so crazy
let's take a look at uh what's going to
happen in this one
also bishop takes f2 and you were saying
you guys were saying something
makes a lot of sense
the whole idea for black is to at some
point challenge this bishop on e4 right
how g5 exactly how g5 is probably a good
move let's go to d8 we got this far
and what did you guys play at g2
king to g2 okay so let's say c6 now the
question is how are you going to develop
this side well i'm going to kick that
knight out
i'm going to play c4 you probably have
to but that gives me this extra square
on b4
basically
at jumping to d3 as well look guys
that's what i'm saying
from a practical perspective it does
feel like white has enough compensation
right right
from an objective perspective well
that's a different story
it doesn't seem like she has because
after queen here
yes even here queen to e2 i'll just
simply go g6 followed by king to g8 and
your attack is not going anywhere that
is the point
of the energy you know what i'm
discovering is being around you two guys
i feel my chest understanding has just
gone way
down i mean i thought carissa was doing
pretty darn good i i think so too again
from a practical perspective i think so
too
now at the same time she has to prove it
right
there will be opportunities for brandon
to go wrong
and for karisa to take over i have no
doubt about that but from an objective
point of view
he is much better right now
by the way i have to correct
ourselves as we came on
we do actually have a result now we do
we do in the senior section uh
max uh took down igor in a game we
thought well you know there was two
extra pawns
uh for maxine there and i've i didn't
see any compensation
that's in pretty smooth sailing it did
it did and he brought home the point
in a very nice way let's just catch up
to it and here it is this was the
head-to-head maximum looking won against
igor helminicki and
that pulls him into first place for the
time being that's right he leapfrogs
over
um
igor navikov yes and larry christiansen
and he
[Music]
thank you guys
absolutely max congratulations a
confident victory i have to stay you
started off the first two games it felt
like you had some chances in those ones
as well i was winning in game one
by a full pawn and i was just thinking
to myself how not to repeat what i did
in round one because i was winning after
14 moves and
then i
had so many possibilities that they just
swarmed my head and i couldn't figure
out how they were because they all
looked winning so i just couldn't make
decisions you're such an experienced
player how do you deal with uh those
type of situations uh
the experience comes also with practice
and that i didn't have for quite some
time so uh but uh i
for this game at least i tried to think
back to game to round one and and try to
avoid what happened round one let's take
a look at this game it felt like you got
a devastating position after 10 moves of
play yeah though i was winning after
nine moves yeah
g4 were you uh what was your first
instinct when you saw this move were you
shocked i was shocked i was like you
know this is not this is not playable
this cannot be playable uh i mean i
think i think black is worried about
queen a5 bishop takes knight yes uh
which is the main idea really and then
maybe i don't know after rook takes
bishop maybe queen d4 i don't know did
you still have some idea some
preparations yeah there's some prep
stuff i mean i've played this so many
times though um but uh
yeah
and and certainly the move before that
black [ __ ] could take with a knight and
go into slightly worse but pl absolutely
playable position knight takes knight
takes pawn takes and after d takes c
queen a5 check
uh followed by queen takes c5 c3 here
and then queen check and queen takes
pawn and white is a little bit better
but you know it's absolutely playable
for black one more question because it
does seem like you're quite experienced
with uh this particular position do you
know what the name of it is
even the london system no no no this
particular e4 variation oh no i don't
it's called the steinitz counter gambit
apparently the tiniest counter game with
my gun okay we have no idea we were
shocked i love playing counter games my
favorite opening when i was a kid was
the fog bear counter again but so you
know here it is okay
a little bit more ridiculous but uh yeah
this is yeah of course d5 has been
played in some famous games back in like
1910 and stuff but um
i i think after pawn takes pawn white
has a slight edge so um and then he
played this move bishop to g4 yeah this
was uh really
yeah so i mean actually actually before
h3 i was thinking maybe you know because
i was trying to make use of the fact
that black cannot go knight d7 ever
because if he goes knight d7 i play c6
and bishop a6 which is will win the rock
on eight so i thought about f3 here
uh and then and then taking and
canceling yes and then so that the
knight d7 i have pawn takes pawn
followed by c6 with this idea that i
just outlined yes uh and yeah this is
kind of
not i mean i don't know this doesn't
look pretty probably then this is over
well sorry
but
so but i thought he'd go bishop d7
anyway because that's the only really
square i thought
i saw for him
um so yeah
yeah i mean still you wanted to take
that one on e4 for free but yeah but
like still this is like come on i mean
okay could this be really playable i
mean i don't know i don't think so but
but so again i had a choice but i said
okay you know let's let's play simple
this time
uh not to repeat my game against dimitri
and uh and because now i'm just winning
a pawn
and and and then i was like yeah yeah
yeah again i thought okay 92 but like
y uh because i thought if the knight
gets to f3 it's actually going to be
stronger so eventually i just took and
then i was like okay what's he going to
figure out how
where is the counter play coming from so
exactly he's he actually
thought of one idea right which is
g6 i think he well first yeah
g6
and then and this is was like the final
i think um calculation that i had to
figure out what to do in his setup and i
saw this idea bishop d2 bishop c3 which
wins another pawn basically very nice
yeah and and and i don't i don't i don't
see what he could do i don't know maybe
no the position after bishop g4 yeah and
and this was a little trick that he
obviously in 94 but that doesn't work
because i double my rooks when he trades
on d4 and goes f5 i just play rook
d1
and you know game over and if he plays
rookie five to double rooks then i just
have rookie three for example
uh
and yeah
no no no yeah rookie three bricks e5
should be uh seven mm-hmm
yeah i mean for example this is
yeah the key is always to have two extra
pawns on one side then that's what i was
trying for against dmitry and i
kept failing horribly
blundered but um
i think i blundered about five different
wins in that game
plus or minus two uh
so yeah but yeah here i just kept all
the counter play at bay basically and
and here was another idea that to just
put the work on e5
and to trade bishops on d5 after that it
seemed
extremely simple um
yeah and nothing much that black could
really do and he kind of
i don't know maybe i have to go for this
one but i always thought
bishop endings up upon are actually
easier to win than broken border next
but yeah this is but yeah i just opened
the game up
i just kept moving things up until yeah
until sure it's time to resign yeah
because on bishop c bishop f5 snuffs it
so
max a very dominant uh victory for you
now we were wondering what are you doing
uh nowadays you're not playing too much
what what are you doing i i i run my my
chess academies uh we have three
locations already open but the plan is
to actually open up like 20 30 locations
in uh tri-state area and then forward
you know towards you know the whole
country um and also i just uh started a
project called chessreach.com
which is basically a way to uh get all
the professional chess players to
offer their services for a minimum
high price
basically the idea is to raise uh
raise the
the pricing on lessons uh and the
ability to take you know
play with grandmasters and iams and
title players and so if anybody wants to
register on chessreach.com either as a
student or as a title player we welcome
that there it's open
and you can just put your time that you
are available the pricing that you like
as long as it meets the minimum criteria
which is quite high
um and uh off you go you know you can
get yourself a student or or or learn
from someone really good definitely a
busy man keeping busy congratulations
max congratulations for the game and
we'll see you in the rest of your games
thank you
max two questions for you please sure uh
repeat it's www
chess
reach yes and reaching out reaching out
and that's where people can get in touch
yeah they they can catch they can find
they uh fill out their profile whether
they're a coach
a title player
it starts with fms goes up to gms
and
or they can fill out their profile as a
student what they're looking for and
they'll be set up with they'll be
matched yeah we're
it's a soft launch for now but once it
gets off there'll be a lot of matches
second it's like a dating service for
learning
tinder for chess
nice just reach right
second question for you
how do you overcome the depression of
letting an opponent off the hook
just like you did with dimitri in the
first round i straightened it easily
very easily i i did the same with black
yesterday and so i felt very good okay
uh but uh but generally um i'm basically
thinking about the
uh tournament three years ago where i
started with one out of six and then
finished with three wins in a row and i
thought you know if i don't start with
uh that kind of score in this tournament
i should be happy right because maybe
maybe i have it in me to win a couple
games down the road soon lovely good
luck nice to see you thank you good luck
with all the ventures 2030 academies
boys across the country chess reach he's
got a lot of ideas and where would you
like to take it i actually want to go
back to the carissa game for a second
because i think
brandon
outplayed oh i'll play carissa in a very
interesting way
how did he do it so he didn't take the
rook immediately
okay so she carissa
offered her offered an exchange yeah and
here we have the move queen e6 who
played instead of bishop takes f2 okay
and the difference is
that if i i want to play knight f6
clear i thought i was playing g5 but if
you played g5 now
is queen h i have queen h3 is that a
real issue
i don't know but so i took a knight
queen takes g3 okay i'm not happy my
kings
are under duress
but
for the moment i'm a piece up can i go
rook d-8
it um checking defeat a handbook it's
legal now i don't want to see rook d1 up
here so i'm not
grabbing the pawn on b2 but where can i
can i
sidestep
i think rook f3 is
mate
rook f3 is mate i think you're right
actually
holy smokes rook f3 is made bishop e3
returning the piece then
it's very lost though it's a very lost
you i mean you picked up a pawn i picked
up a pun
i mean a good point yeah yeah yeah yeah
so it means i can't get in the desired
g5 because you've got queen
h3 that's a problem that's a problem
christian yep
that's a big problem actually
that that's a good problem coming to f6
your compensation no that was the whole
point right yeah the bishop on e4 was
supposed to be indomitable you can't
move it
the immovable object um it was a
difficult moment knight xd5 as i was
mentioning was offering an opportunity
for karissa to go king to g2 or start
with queen to e4 right and uh then after
bishop takes f2 king to g2 very
difficult sequence to find especially
with just a few minutes on the clock and
if i'm not mistaken right now she's down
to her last 13 minutes
we've seen this in uh carissa's first
two games
uh that
sh she's a thinker oh she's not usually
a thinker that's the thing about her but
in this tournament in particular it's
been the case
both games uh yesterday especially i
think she had like
correct me if i'm wrong uh a minute or
so something
moves yeah it was something disastrous
not not
that much fun she puts a lot of pressure
on herself
by uh consuming so much time and by the
way that move king g2 that would have
been a very hard move yeah i think for
anybody uh queen e4
as you were suggesting uh christian
computer lion i mean i know
and somebody grabs your rook and if your
instinct is not to retake the bishop you
know
discover checkers
i mean but king g2 oh
[Music]
and by the way also psychologically
maybe it's not that easy because right
now after king to g2 and let's leave
that position on the board
black does have the option of just
simply going queen takes f3 and that is
a pawn in the end gate right upon in the
end game the rook is coming with check
the other rook is coming with checks so
black is still nursing quite a
significant advantage nevertheless is
not as significant as what we are seeing
right now exactly after queen to e6 um
to me
it looks almost lost at this point if
you don't have g5 and you have to allow
knight f6 yeah that you can't allow
knight upset that's just pretty much
over yeah queen e6 all right uh let's
take a look at the game between
christopher you and pedro espinosa from
this section the juniors because i think
this one
is just completely wild but unless i'm
missing something
it might just be over
[Music]
my gosh i mean
i'm used to
wait wait exchange slots
where the pawn structure weak squares
where you have a pot on default exactly
this is explosive what the heck
uh
so what happened in this game well even
even this looks more or less normal this
looks acceptable yeah acceptably right
normal right
this looks okay this looks normal e4 e4
this kind of blows open all right
i'm i'm completely puzzled
two moves two moves ago actually not
even two moves one move ago
okay this position was zero zero zero
zero zero zero
so after he takes d5 two moves ago
instead of queen to f4 apparently king
to d8 was still equal now damn why sorry
sorry what
dang leaving the knight you just said
equal and left can you show me that
position
you i mean c6 is hanging
and the guy was like you don't want to
be zero no no problems
you got this what are the pitchforks
away
no but taking on c6 queens
queen two f for this is just a losing
for a white right because you're getting
check made it so you cannot always say
you cannot take there what you can do
actually is take on h6 in fact is the
only way to continue this one and
maintain the balance for white what
after check this sequence out
queen to f4 king to h1
the only move
only move
wow otherwise you're minus eight minus
nine right so you can resign on the spot
because queen takes g4 is coming on the
board h1 king to h1 and now that was
once again almost the only move for
black
is rook to f6
yeah wait is it you go rookie right now
we just get positioned
commentary i'm done
the game itself has
did not go in that direction no sure
what you said clean f4 allowed queen
takes easy six check
checking to d8 and now knight to e4 and
this is just all she wrote because well
well now not only we're defending this
knight is beautiful right but we're
defending against rook g3 as well as
rook f2 exactly region was played
exactly rook to g3 i don't know what
this board does we have to take it takes
g3s will come through on the borders no
follow-up absolutely no follow-up you
can give one more check but then i just
simply go king to h3 king the h3 of
course yes that's one of the ways
king to g1 also completely winning um
but king to h3 and maybe this is
this was a draw between
uh
dagupati and brodsky we had claimed that
draw on broadcast
yes you did it i did it i did an
executive order on that one or exactly
like once
yeah why is this winning king h3o bishop
takes and this is perhaps what he missed
what pedro espinosa missed between e3
bishop takes a g3 queen to e3 is winning
completely
yeah okay but also knight to d2
this is another way to win the position
knight to d
right and you're just throwing that
queen away and g3 is hanging f1 is now
protected or you can go queen to eat and
we might be saying this variation
because king h3 on the board
by christopher you uh christopher you
right so and clearly pedro was right
bishop yeah but knight d2 that's that is
a cold shower yeah yeah that closes the
door this is the game yeah yeah
and this is official balaji tango
a draw against david brought give a
fascinating classical sicilian but which
seemed to be mostly theory mostly theory
yeah right and the players really did
play
uh down the main fairway in that game
all right so let's go back to this one
we were looking at it between
christopher you and pedro because big
game for christopher it's a big game for
christopher you he scores if he wins
this one two and a half two and a half
points including already surviving
against a wonder with the black pieces
yesterday where he was worse right yeah
destroying brandon jacobson in the first
round that's another big competitor yeah
exactly he's played his tournament he
started with two of the highest rated
players now is playing the lowest rated
so right taking opportunity of his white
here right so bishop g3 on the board and
we are expecting this move knight d i
think queen e3 is much cleaner at least
from a practical point of view right
what's wrong with 82
except that knight d2 is so compelling
christian i mean you're attacking the
queen yes yes and defending the rule
corner that's the thing you defend the
rogue so black's choices are actually
very limited exactly
he's going through it yes
and then you go queen e3 and then queen
e3 and the night just happened to be
closer
f1 92 playing on the board and i think
uh pedro whoops
and it's easy in these you know we've
got a chess engine we're sitting here
looking at each other going what pieces
are flying but it's very very clear
to my mind that in those variations that
christians were showing there's some
unbelievable complications i mean if you
find king h1 and you find rook h6 and no
that was ridiculous right like seriously
even the concept of playing king d8
first just not to allow queen takes c6
with chuck right it's easy to miss
totally you know everything's hanging
you're giving your own checks right and
it's easy to not even come up with the
move indeed indeed and i want to go to
our ladies section for just a second and
jump into the game of sophie morris
against gracie sophie has been nursing a
very nice space advantage for some time
but she hasn't made much out of it and
it feels to me that black's pieces are
kind of coming alive the rook will seize
the open file
maybe this knight which remember it was
when we played b4 or a7 yeah it might
end up on e8 and f6 this knight could
come around and i feel like well white
really hasn't done too much in the last
five six moves and again sophie leading
the tournament with two out of two uh
jumped jumping to the game of um hold on
that was i was looking for the game of
jennifer yeah there we are
uh versus ellen this was the game where
jennifer was like coming with guns
blazing
um
still like white yeah but but uh not as
clear right not as clear she's
jennifer is
you know
again one two and this game has finished
in the drawer to interrupt you joel
benjamin has drawn his game against
grisha kaidanov
nothing much happened in this kind of
quiet
french
steiner version thank you herman steiner
u.s champion dude no you're his 48 how
did i not know this i mean let it slip
by
[Laughter]
um but to finish the
we'll we'll get to the joel game in just
a second to finish the thought of
jennifer and ellen again i'm thinking if
jennifer can get in these moves rook d7
rook rook g7 queen takes g2
finally she will really be crashing
through
uh
with her kingside attack long time in
coming
um
first
thoughts
bishop f4 i said by force an annoying
move to face though because it virtually
provokes queen g4 unless you're really
really sure
that you're going to go queen h5 rook d7
rook g7
um
queen g4
shall we yeah
queen g4 you can play i think i'll play
king h2 oh king h2 you're not even
taking okay well
good i understand
just asking rook rook d7 i
i'm channeling my inner jennifer you at
the moment i see uh
yeah i mean everything forward so how do
we feel about going like a move like f
three just right it's a little asking
for it i get it yeah i mean your queen
could end up you could end up regretting
this but right but
oh yeah perhaps black can actually
actually has some chances right rook g7
right g3 is coming g7 rook g2 is coming
it's a huge game for both players but
i'm thinking most especially for
jennifer because she needs to catch
up uh with the tournament leaders and
again in the seniors we do have two
results max has won
his game early yes and as you said not
too much happened in this whole
ending with joel
i although i must say that just about
right here i thought joel was the one
with a little push i mean we could bring
up the analysis board for that thank you
yeah just somewhere around here now i
don't know if he
needed knight d7 looks a little bit
peculiar to my eyes
well one thing about that game i have a
feeling we're probably going to have one
of these players good they can explain
it to us
i'm sure we're going to do it
you're all about it right right here all
about it and i just want to move to the
game of larry's versus
next because
more trades
not too much is happening this was the
isolated queen pawn position
and as we do have another surprising
result
igor novikov drew against alexander
shabollov and i have no idea how that
happened they found
a repetition weirdest
repetition ever ever what what why not
go rookie too first of all seriously
right
uh we thought
that igor with this
huge
stage advantage was really going to
press it
and it was just knight h2 knight g4
i think uh igor was shocked by his
advantage and didn't know how to
how to uh deal with although by this
point i have to say it probably has
diminished quite a bit
has it it still feels like okay i liked
your suggestion yeah but i i i actually
think i go at five
just
ah
close
that might actually be a darn good move
right yeah just uh
16 pawns
i'm not going to get an a4 very easily
am i i'm going to have to bring my
knight to c3 my bishop to d1 we're not
getting that okay fine fine find that
perfectly played game perfect beautiful
another game in that section that's
about to end in it i assume we'll end in
a draw at some point is the game between
vladimir kopian and dimitri gorevich
as we were expecting by the way the game
between christopher you did end in a win
with the white pieces i guess
okay there was a lot of extra pieces in
that game by the way uh this was the
extra pawn game remember knight takes a2
and we were saying that vladimir kopian
against dimitri grimage game yeah we
left it off
bishop c4 was that necessary
no actually but this is already not so
good for a white hat why because after
knight takes b7 what what what
knight b7
yes that's not afraid that is that's no
way pawn two no way i i think on d1 i go
rook b8 okay it's only black and when
this goes wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait let's go wish me six
but i have bishop d5 yeah
yeah would rook be it first though first
so yeah we've got to get this if you
have to go 95 rupees with that then i'm
not happy you're not happy
okay it looks like after knight d6
bishop c4 this is how they got into
bishops of opposite color they played
for some time
until eventually they said what are we
doing
draw agree no no i didn't have to agree
i said i expect that sometimes
i thought it was drawing greed i mean
because it looks pretty drunk
that was it
and here are a couple of games that have
concluded uh yasser the game between
igor novikov and alexander shabollov i
love the hat yep two points for igor one
point for alexander certainly a slow
start there for shabba dabba and
christopher you with a blistering star
two and a half points as we expected
from one of the top seeds in the event
actually i think he's my top and he's my
pick for the event what i want to say
yes pedro spidoza would have a point
well not not a lot of points but
remember that he is
severely outraged in this tournament and
i want to say that was the second black
out of three so yeah tough event for him
uh christopher you has his eye on the
game between andrew and a justin because
after all it was andrew who started uh
with two out of two and this game three
versus three very very reduced material
so i do expect to draw in this game
justin one guy andrew yeah yeah just too
little material right right the bishop
is better than tonight but
it's not enough not enough at this point
so christopher will be thinking
okay come on justin make a draw and let
me get a tie for first and christian
turning to you what caught your eye
well guys yes because we're actually
setting up for an interview right now
he's getting set up for interview i
apologize yeah we have five games
remaining in the u.s junior girls every
single player is still really fight so
we can take a look at a couple of games
that perhaps we haven't taken out uh in
a while
okay this was the jennifer u game this
is the uh sophie game where i kind of
think that black has improved
and which game uh perhaps the talia game
we haven't seen in a bit this is the
rochelle wu this one we haven't seen at
all at all
so let's just take a again
we just see the move h5 knight c4 uh two
bishops
was it a gary site two bishops ambitious
very good uh
flag for choice we can probably bring
this in the analysis board so okay the
audience follows oops excuse me
that was uh i was trying to
show that the knight is under attack but
be careful queen a1
queen a one check uh is what rochelle is
thinking
as well
and if you i don't like it i really
don't like it this is the type of move
you just
never want to play when you have the
night to leave
the central square so i suppose she'll
play bishop to
d3 protecting the knight
anticipating that after queen check
might be time to run
and invite queen h1 we prefer black in
this position we do but we have
christian with a gaston studio thank you
alejandro we are indeed with a
christopher you christopher a sharp
victory
take us through the emotions of this
game it looked completely wild for us
yeah
i was definitely very confused by most
of the game too
i it was hard to really understand what
was going on or what the evaluation was
how did you assess it at different
moments of this game did you feel like
you got the better out of him out of the
opening
i think i preferred my position a bit
but i expected a much more
normal game where he just castles and i
definitely didn't anticipate the way he
played with queen f6 king e7
let's take a look
queen to f6 bishop to g6
he did have the two bishops he did have
a potential attack via the h file were
you at all concerned at this point or
did you feel secure
within your position
i felt relatively safe because i have
this work on h1 kind of stopping his
pawns yes
stopping the move h5
and he played f5
he was really taking the fight to you in
this one pedro
and uh
you
retaliated as well queen to f7 queen to
e2
what was the critical moment of the game
in your opinion as we entered these wild
complications
i'm on i'm honestly not really sure what
the most critical moment was but i
thought it was like
a big mistake this whole plan with rick
g8 g6 work f6
i think maybe he should have just tried
to bring his knight to e7
and g6 quickly
so he's like
d7 maybe yeah came to d7
and how would you have responded to that
what was uh your plan nightway for or
i'm not exactly sure i was considering a
lot of moves here
like work h5 knight a4
we're definitely among the top moves i
was considering
so your focus was to
swing between the weakness on h6 and the
weakness potentially of the king on the
queen side yeah and then you guys got to
this position and uh
i will
give you a little bit of insight into
the uh assessment of it by the engines
and we were completely shocked by it did
you see this move at this point what
were your candidate moves that you were
considering
at this after taking on d5 did you
consider anything else but queen f4
i i didn't really think he had anything
good besides queen f4
king to d8 apparently was
in fact
equal
oh wow
that's just insane it is wow
and after queen to f4 it is you who
actually have to start playing for uh
equality it seems
queen to f4 i believe it was
what was it uh
it's rook h6 games no no no i think this
is already over because
g4 is a problem
so you have to take on h6
going to f4 and now king to h1 is the
only way for you to make a draw crazy
so what's like the what's the whole
variation after king h1 after king h1
it's a draw by repetition after rook f6
0k
wow
yeah wow wow was right that was uh
christopher that was our feelings too
like we wanted to shoot the messenger
it's amazing that christian is still
alive
[Laughter]
but uh
once you played queen takes e6 it was
this boss move knight e4 you you had
calculated
actually the game variation pretty uh
well after this we thought that you were
you you you were pretty certain of a
victory
uh thanks to this knight d2
christopher two and a half out of three
that's a pretty good score how would you
assess your performance so far
very good
very good very good winning when you
have to it definitely seems like you're
on the right track thank you very much
for joining us and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you thank you and by the
way during the interview a number of
games finished
larry christensen made a draw that's
right larry christensen made a draw
against nick the fermions of the
comical and collected california cool
i'll finish in a draw as larry moves to
two points uh catches up with igor
navikov and max lugi who are also on two
points and nick continues his steady
roll with 50
exactly only one game remaining um in
the seniors vladimir versus dimitri
we're expecting that game to head for a
draw but in the girls section you have
everything to play for absolutely yeah
absolutely and tell ya
how to tell you lose her dark square
bishop i wanted to see talia uh having a
dark square bishop that was sitting on
c3 and we left it we remember i thought
she had really tricked her opponent and
she did the queen d1
and
she did get this
oh i wanted to see somehow
maybe this king first of all get the
king off of this diagonal right
somehow i want the bishop on c3
so
that it's eyeballing the king side but
she played bishop
and
oh
that's one reason why you want your king
off the diagonal
and uh
zoe
managed
to win the dark square bishop back
good deal for black though
yeah i thought so i thought well i would
like to if i was white i would like to
have a bishop on c3 versus a knight on
d4
but i think he wasn't on c3 it wasn't
that was great
funny you should mention that why wasn't
the bishop on z well in this case
uh
okay if you unfortunate
okay let's imagine i played bishop c1
which is kind of what i wanted to do
you're going to go back to d4 aren't you
probably i actually don't like this with
knight f5 even if you leave the bishop
there okay so right here you would you
would have been looking for b5 something
i don't know if it's time to break e5 d5
something h5 demon but age five somehow
i think that knight on d4 is very
important for black okay well we'll take
a look at this in a bit as we have a
special guest with us
thank you alejandro i am with a legend
of american chess joel benjamin joel
first of all welcome back to st louis
welcome back to the show how does it
feel to be playing over the board chess
once again
it feels kind of weird because my last
tournament was in november
and i played very very sparingly
so
i think i need the first few rounds to
to kind of get warmed up and um you know
i've
i've had some pretty good positions but
um
you know when we get late in the
struggle i have to have that energy you
know be able to summon up that energy to
put them through it's still a much
better start compared to last year last
year was pretty rough in the first few
rounds i was very conscious of that to
make you know that it was okay if i have
a modest start but i have to avoid that
disaster in the beginning and i think
that i'll be stronger towards the end
absolutely and let's take a look at
today's game how did you approach
today's round
well um i guess one of my favorites i
played kaidanov many times historically
i have an excellent score with white and
a very poor score with black
so
he's also maybe the hardest opponent to
beat with white in the tournament so
it's kind of like
the edge that i get with the white
pieces is small
but the big advantage is not having the
black pieces because that's gonna be a
rough ride
um but the games that i've won from him
generally have not been because of the
opening and um you know
all of us are trying to think of just
some way to get out of the opening with
that without him just totally
neutralizing because his his opening
repertoire is incredibly tight
do you see him as probably the most
dangerous player in this field when it
comes to opening preparation
yes
yes
because he's just he's almost he's
almost unbeatable you have to you have
to manage to get
uh to get a position to play and i kind
of thought that i did that and then
uh you know suddenly after queen d5 i
realized that he's got another one of
those you know kaidana of liquidating
sequences and he's calculated all the
tactics and
well let me
if you don't mind let me take back a
couple of moves okay absolutely uh to
start with the position of the bishop d2
knight 35 rook e8
bishop to d2 i've had this position
before okay i had this position against
vanderstern in 1994.
vanderstern
was a similar kind of cat to kaidanov he
answered e4 with e5 and d4 with d5 so i
did the same thing c4 e6 e4 and i got to
this position
which he he thought
was nothing uh special but he played
here night before and after knight e4
he regretted that move because the
tactics are suddenly
a big problem so he had to go knight
back to d5 he just lost a lot of time
so i had this position on the on the
board
this morning but you did spend 15
minutes up to this point
where you yeah well i'm not andrew i'm
not andrew hong you know
no nobody i played the ship d2 but i was
also thinking about the uh
you know sometimes i get this type of
position i try to channel norman's mises
because norman's mises is the high
priest of this variation okay he plays
this all the time he opens with c4 and
probably like two-thirds of his
opponents play e6 because they want to
try out this opening
and uh
i've seen a lot of games he displays
knight e2 just avoids the train he
brings the knight to g3 just keeping
tension in the position but then i
thought bishop d2 okay you know i just
couldn't help just connecting my rooks
you know before
you know before doing anything
and uh
i didn't anticipate knight takes c3
because the engine said that knight c7
was the best move and i didn't look at
the second best move so i'm really
probably the engine just thought that
knight takes c3 is is a very small
advantage you didn't think about knight
c3 like andrew hong in the shower
the problem is that that i i don't look
at one opening obsessively and i looked
at a few different things that might
happen of course there's many there's
many ways that black can play this
opening
i could not find a single game on the
database that kaidana faced c4 and e4
so i i didn't know what i thought that
you were going to surprise you
i i'm sure i didn't you probably did i
definitely surprised him
and he played in the most conventional
way not necessarily the best way black
has all uh many other good options but
um yeah i'm kicking myself for not not
looking at this in advance because maybe
i could have thought something of
something to do but here um
you know i i tried to calculate queen f5
at queen d3 but
just somehow
my piece is just in the wrong place he
has
you know there's a problem that um
you know that some lines he can
no i that that
no no rookie six i thought rookie six is
is what he does on queen f5 that was the
problem i didn't know how to answer
rookie six
because
do you have some funny ideas knight
takes f7 probably not but okay but right
now i'm pinned after c4 sorry okay but
then queen takes d4
and and and uh queen takes
and rook takes e1 yeah i have all my
pieces hanging and queen takes d2 yeah
so knight f7 doesn't work
yeah so i couldn't see how to organize
it i couldn't see how to get in the move
c4
um i thought about queen d3
um i thought he could maybe play c5
you know rook rook d8 is also possible
c5 maybe is the most annoying
i just didn't see anything
i don't know if the engines have any
better ideas than i did but no no i
think the engine wanted to go into the
uh
as you did well but also now i saw c4
knight b4 and then i was racking my
brain about i could have tried c4 first
and then knight d7
i realized that later and if night
before maybe knight d7 is possible but i
think that basically yeah not a lot it's
just not a lot not a lot joe uh pre-tame
start for you three draws are we about
to see fireworks in the next few rounds
well i hope that i'm going to put a win
on the board
and feeling just a little bit better
every day
and
you know hopefully
next time i'm here i'll have you know
something more to talk about
guys joe i got a quick question for you
yeah one of the great benefits of course
of being a commentator is i get to
sacrifice all of your pieces
did it ever occur to you to sacrifice
and exchange rook takes e6 f takes e6
queen d3 and just play the position
uh i got it on oh sorry uh you
i don't see the position yet there you
go so you just play rook i mean yeah i
know i know the engine the i know i saw
this on the engine
but i didn't understand it so i didn't
want to do it
[Laughter]
well you just play bishop h6 bishop d2
rookie one mesh medinav channel your
internet medina
yeah i mean nobody has tried this over
the board i did i did see it come up on
the engine okay but i just didn't i just
didn't know what to make of it
and i thought i could just uh you know
just play normal moves but
um
it is a possibility i was wondering if
it was even possible to take on e6
immediately when he played bishop e6 but
that i did not i did not look on the
computer at that which i was kind of
kicking myself that you know um but um
but i was thinking about uh that but um
i don't know um
well you got to make a nostradamus out
of me because i've chosen you to win the
tournament so i don't want to put the
pressure on you
it's time to perform baby smart is
picked up
isn't going to cut it
you got to win well the thing is the
thing is um
for me
the tournament is not about um
about
just playing ability
i don't worry about that i'm just
worried about
you know physical and chest conditioning
that's that's the biggest obstacle for
me
and you know i'm just i'm managing it
day by day
and so if i can conquer that then i you
know maybe can start putting some wins
on the board but you know you have to
realize the oscar that i'm i'm
you know in the in the top group of
rustiest players in the in the field
so that makes me kind of a long shot
all right i like it thank you joel
though thank you the the the the top
half of the rusty field
we see here our picks before the senior
championship
joel benjamin hey i'm telling you joel
he's coming yeah he's coming appreciated
he he's playing himself with the form
you see that
confidence
is coming it's beginning to brew
the brew is happening
thank you joel thank you joel
as we have all the results actually in
the scene and the scenery yes we
actually have all the results we'll
probably look at the standings at some
point but we still have plenty of games
remaining in the juniors and in the
junior girls we actually have the
opposite scenario in which we have every
game still going yeah
and we have the standings for the
seniors with three rounds already
completed uh larry christian eager
novikov and maxine delugie are all tied
for first place but two out of three
only a plus one score which means
there's a bunch of people following them
up with a 50 score uh gregor kaidanov
dimitri gurevich vladimir akopian joel
benjamin and nick the fermion
notice you got in a little russian
accent there what happened we we kind of
you you
tuned in and channeled your interruption
uh rook isa do you speak a little
russian
you don't speak any russian
i liked it okay i just uh saw the game
of jennifer um
versus ellen this was i think i think
it's time
what i mean let's look take a look at
the game between ellen wang and jennifer
you time to sacrifice i mean if you
don't play rook g3 let's go baby you
gotta go right let's go let's do it
there will never be a better time
right right i totally agree with that
and by the way if you do delay a little
bit too long yeah something could go
wrong uh for you i could get a check and
and mess you up rook g3 let's do it
commentators curse guys rook to d7 was
played no
oh not rook d7 rook d7
cries of anguish could be heard
throughout the central west end oh that
move does not belong with the position
whatsoever
rook just come from d7 yes it did but
yes it is it is guys let's let's go with
that rook g3 just to show the audience
absolutely you take it back take and now
the queen is trapped it's got a kind of
h2 h2 or h1 i think one f3
now i take on h4 right
okay you do sure i think so well if i do
defend passively with 21 i think
you might have some h3 ideas and that's
probably i i definitely have h3 ideas
yeah i mean
yeah no
white's got what about queen takes
queen what queen takes h3 oh
ooh
queen h oh
no but this is
of this type of positions i'm up a queen
because
right the tactics should give me that
pawn on d4 come on i'm not even going to
calculate this has to work it takes we
can play
knight d4 oh no i like it for black i'm
feeling feeling is good this is groovy
i've got good feelings here i don't like
this you're feeling it i i understand
that but
i love it when christmas
that doesn't let us you know the
vultures are ready to pounce yeah i
agree with you guys
slowly slowly yeah but
uh rook 27 was played now rook to b1 uh
well i just wanted to say again
i think queen takes h4 was the right
queen takes h4 yes and
queen e3 king h2 king h2
and just a second let's let's hold on
yes
i could take that rook right you can
indeed and it's attacking the other rook
correct which is a good thing i assume
but you play rook takes b7 thread
no i think i'm gonna start with queen to
h8 first start with queen h8 why not
okay well that's a that's a good
question and i go rook takes b7
oh and against my rook my attention was
too in 97 but queen h7 queen
h7 that's annoying at least a draw i can
also take on g3 right
correct just simply take on g3
wow
good stuff i mean
i got to tell you in a blitz game i'm
going for rook g3 jennifer went instead
a different direction altogether she
played rook d7
rook b1
queen h7 the defensive and that's what
i'm thinking too seizing the defense
this is not looking good i don't know
anymore no white's got everything
including at some moment
you're gonna under mine this knight yeah
right i'm gonna 5a5 right i'm going to
drop
if i ever get my rook to b6 in my pawn
to a6 boy
uh jennifer's in trouble
i agree i think this she's overplaying
her hand yeah i think that this rook g7
i don't know if she missed something
down the line of rook g3 we didn't see
it as so clear i think she was just not
happy with a draw maybe she calculated
everything that we looked at and she was
just not happy with the draw did we end
that
i think you had some perpetual yes i
might have had but yes so uh we'll keep
an eye on this one and
i wanted to uh just say that i think
sophie's in trouble
our tournament leader why is her county
too she brought her king from g1 to e2
exactly gracie uh and i didn't like this
decision by white one bit sophie put her
king there
remember she was the one who had the
space advantage she had the the better
pieces and now i'm seeing black's pieces
uh really
jump into
good squares
vault into good squares i like
black's position sorry i wanted to also
check in on carissa
forgive me for this uh because that was
an amazing game going on
carissa is busted guys
what happened here
well uh we left it back here at these
parts
oh this was the wonderful queenie
that brandon
came up with okay five a five what
all right submission g5 there's no
knight well there's knight f6 well
there's the knight f6 move that's the
bother there's some move yeah
e4 i like that move breaks up in the
okay
i'm not a big fan i can i take and take
with my bishop on e4 i'm upon
a material down
but i've got an anchored bishop
i don't think so you're not happy i mean
the
king's too weak i think nobody believes
me
i won't press it
g5 by brandon whoa whoa
c5 oh because bishop d4 was a threat
yeah what is that the punch defender
what am i doing what is going on this
game christian oh this he's playing
great moves of chess because right now
he's uh he's in control
he has no problems there is no more
counter chances given that you have the
two bishops controlling both the light
and the dark squares but you don't have
any entry squares and he's taking them
away one by one especially this last
move c5 i really love but what is the
actual tactical justification of this
let's go back to the analysis board that
yasser has right now
uh g5 bishop takes queen edge five
yeah absolutely right
here g5 yeah it takes that kind of came
out of the blue
c5
so if i play like rook d1
i is rook f2 winning is this the point
perhaps i i'll go rook to e6 i don't
think it's winning i don't think rook to
f2 is winning
rook to f2 why would that be winning
you've got to check
one check
i can also throw in rook cafe by the way
instead of playing queen h1 right away
right yes
that might be i'm still getting on my
sneakers and
oh this queen g1 mate right no i have
rook d8 check oh
here you're threatening to kill me but
this move carissa
look at her sneaking in
i mean i don't know
i don't know i don't know but rook f2 go
ahead sorry all right guys teresa has to
make a decision very soon she's down
under one minute right now on the clock
with still
six moves to go okay
but
i i'm with alejandro 100 my rook on a1
has got it got into the game i mean
five is coming right now rook a1 is
doing nothing that's fine so let's try
to improve our position after rook d1
e6
rook to d5 let's go oh shoot i'm driving
between the h3 thank you very much yes
that's that's a big deal rook to d1 is
on the board so queen rook to e6 without
wait what if i start with queen to h3
what do you do
what is your point queen
immediately now i guess you want to play
what bishop f4 how do you defend that
pawn on g3 i'm thinking of taking the
pawn on c5 and trying to prove your
words but that's actually not so bad
bishop c5 if i could ever get ambitious
d4 wow the dream yeah yeah that is the
key square yeah but there's no made
right no i don't see it let's see it
right nike
you can take on g3 queen g2
clear as i want it to be no no no no no
no no
exactly so let's go a rook to e6 and
then i was going to do the same he keeps
playing this move rook e6 but i don't
know
if you go queen to h3 i have a feeling
like you probably get checkmated somehow
because i haven't i know f1 is made no
no i have queen e1 so i take on g3 the
phone is made guys it's made in two come
on or that all right
[Applause]
well the other one was checkmate in
three so it wasn't like a big difference
wait a minute what was the check made in
three weeks g3 and then queenie one
queen ew because there's no rook on the
first very nice there
uh by the way i'm being told that justin
wang and andrew hong and
which means there's a tie for first
there's a time for first place in the
juniors between andrew hong and
christmas for you precisely uh so we
can't so you're saying after rookie six
basically that puts the kibosh
on the plan of a rook d5 which is i
can't refute it but i also can't explain
to you what the move rook e6
does actually does well i have a clear
idea and that is uh to potentially swing
that rook either to g6 after queen to h3
either to h6 so imagine queen to h3
knight takes e3 take the bishop and then
rook g6 or rook h6 i like all right okay
so if i just throw the gun that far
right i'll say okay all right do your
worst it's bad it's bad i'm going to
close my eyes
hope for the best are you sure okay
let's let's go i'll take that four i'm
not even calculating right
yes
let's see if it works rogue g6 right
okay okay so now i've got rook check you
can give one check let me throw some
patties let me give the one check i have
it let me feel good about my life g7 yes
king i mean i'm not going to go rook g8
no no no no now this bishop's
that's fine i go 93 and you're queen on
each yeah
oh
your queen is hanging you can't start
with f5 but it doesn't matter knight
needs reach free check picks up the
queen 93 yeah yeah
uh i don't think you can give another
check yes but this is what we call spike
checks i go king of f8 i get closer to
your anyway
at this point or can you
just hide away right over there there's
no continuation it's just over that's
why
it's so powerful yeah
but it's a difficult move to see it's
not a difficult movement
to make it's a move that when you put it
on the board and you start refuting it
yes you have to agree with the engine
right the difficulty with this kind of
moves like rookie six is just even
thinking of them yeah right like coming
you think about queen h3 right right
three rookies
you want to mate the person you can look
at
yeah you have to calculate you have a
calculator right it might just be
checkmate yeah right if he finds rookie
six though
what is the uh evolve for other moves
that are not rookie six out of curious
well rookie six is one of them um rook
f6 with the same idea is another one
rook two c8 is another one
i guarantee you it will not be to defend
upon c5 it doesn't make a lot of sense
again it's all about this idea of
getting the queen to age
and not dropping the pawn on c5 right
it's all about that idea if you don't
understand that idea then it becomes
because
white does have a threat
and that is the move b4 yes yeah yeah i
don't know what rook cia does against it
okay
now that you've inspired us thank you
for this
if you are where's the where's the go
ahead and kill us again that's okay
let's go um
rook g6 or let's go g6 why not okay so
i slurp upon
again i'm covering my eyes you know not
i like
come on baby
bishop d4 okay actually let me try to be
a bit smarter about things okay um
let's go back
b can i start with queen to h3 first all
right green h3 no i still
he's like
the same patterns we saw
although i'm worried that you could just
take on g3 and maybe my king ends up
actually later on after g6 getting
trapped on uh but you still have bishops
before d4 you're not actually mating me
right ninety-five king h1 somewhere yeah
it's it's not that bad it's not made
it's kind of scary but it's not it's not
it feels scary that i could
rook f3 rook four you have ideas you
have ideas but
i mean okay i know it's scary for black
that this doesn't work out and the
bishops actually get active no right
right big moment
he's dropping down to his last four
minutes as well he's been thinking for
five i mean this is a huge moment of the
game
critical moment guys critical moment
six players same idea excellent
execution yes
good move by the way brandon comes into
this competition not as the highest
rated player that honor belongs to a
wonderly young at 2700 but
is brandon the second highest rated
player in the field no i think uh 2600
isn't it
brenda should be around 25.40 i think
well
holiday ratings
i just saw the invitation
all ratings he should be is 26 something
yeah yeah but i want to say that i was
the third i want to say
is fifth then it has to be christopher
you
who's second seed here come on how do we
not know this
let's do it
and this is 26-27 that's what i'm saying
maybe he's the second yeah i think he's
the second rated at least by
invitational rating
was deadly rook f6 was simply deadly
because after rook d5 queen h3 anderson
resignation time yeah
what a move looking for something what a
move rook f1 says she missed rook f1
check
what no no no no i just playing bishop
f4
she's playing bishop before who takes
that four yeah
wow yeah this is adjustable rook f6 was
such a classy move yeah that was very
good
that was very very very good
rook a6 was excellent great fine and he
spent and once again this is about
finding
the right move at the right i should
just resize it knight takes e3 was
coming yeah yeah
uh not to take anything away from me
yeah yeah yeah not not to take anything
away from brandon's success
but i really feel that chris had lost
this game out of the opening yeah what
this preface i mean excuse me but rookie
two f5
and she was not thankful i don't agree
okay she came back she did she was back
in the game if she wouldn't have taken
on d5 if she found that move g3 all she
had to do was get off that pin with the
move king to g2 but she came back is the
thing right right he shouldn't be on the
back foot from the opening with white
exactly that's how white works no but
you're making a very good point that she
didn't end up in that situation yeah and
then she fought back she she did have
that moment for king g2 and i agree with
that completely i mean guys she was
completely lost out of the opening
yesterday against david brodsky that was
a plus three situation right this one
was a minus uh 1.5 not that bad right
and she came back in the middle game in
both cases guys we we must we must go to
the game of sophie
sorry
just results to get the manager justin
wanting to andrew hong there's two two
and a half but they're running out of
time this is a fascinating position
which one uh the their leader sophie
mori suzuki against gracie prasanna and
yeah we
sacrificed an exchange did white
uh yeah let's go to the analysis board
because black's last move to me oh
wow look at this
she missed she missed rook takes d7 what
but why not knight g5 that's a very good
question what happens after knight takes
h6 right now
hold on uh i'm catching up excuse me
what is this g5
that's uh what do you expect g5 i
thought d7 was hanging
knight e7 check queen takes d7
but that's fine then i at least i can
get some counter chances right okay
first of all where do you move your king
that's that's the key point i think i'm
going to h7 okay then let me oh wait
wait wait wait no no no no no no no not
h7 i go king of faith and then rook 87.
yeah king favorite k7 i think king f8
queen takes d7 or k7 you still have
queen c6 though
that's this is the second i wait a
minute what's the body count
two pieces for a rook no you have queen
c6 i think you're still winning here
so maybe it was winning anyway yeah
maybe yeah maybe wait wait wait guys
guys maybe oops excuse me no you're
right yeah queen c6 let's get to the
game position because after queen g4 i
mean after g5
double threat this is made
oh my goodness g5 knight takes h6 oh
well i mean for sophie wait a minute
this could be three out of three three
out of three that would be an excellent
start for her wow that's just over here
you make her an honorary sir one
three out of three that's just wonderful
what does that even mean
wait did you just say an honorary sarah
three out of three that's pretty good
that's what we heard
you like points i get it i take it i'll
take them so i i think you just make
right like yes bishop g5 looks like
that looks like it's mate i think it is
with the thread of uh discover check and
the point is that actually with black
you're also close to checkmating me
but you want to move away one move too
far because when you go rk2 in any sort
of variations
then i go king d1 so i think i have to
go king h7 right after knight takes g5
queen takes g5 king h7 is probably the
only move
right and so you do have but rook a2
check as you were saying no no no after
knight g5 yeah we will still get there
because
i think knight f5 forces rook a2 but now
i have king d1 uh yeah it's just a
chance check on a1
kings two another one
maybe bishop b1 now yeah i was about to
say maybe that's no but then
exactly
it's not over
that's funny it's not
guys where's the mate
she did not play bishop takes g5 she
just said look
by the way uh with 30 seconds on the
clock she made her last move oh and
there's still three moves but she's
good move and what about now queen
h5 will attacks the knight
queen f
queen h6 check a slight jab a slight jab
to the knight but what if i go knight
df6
knight df6 looks kind of box right i
would like to play with knight a chap
six but i think that's made in one
you know it's funny i wanted to go queen
h6
king e8 bishop takes b5 check oh don't
take the bishop because of 1966
but you take the bishop with check
it doesn't leave me wondering why on
earth this king is on e2 but i don't
think that right i mean we'll never get
an answer to that don't take the bishop
because knight takes 36.
we'll win your queen but wait a minute
so wait what what is the current
position position we got knight df6
checking f6 is on the board
and we made we may move forward so the
players can chill and they should chill
right now take stock of what's happened
right
first of all body count
up in exchange for a pawn
but with the move bishop takes g5 i'm
only afraid of
rook a2 maybe can i play bishop e3
before capturing but why would i chase
the black king
to the center of the board when it was
you know what i think she's missed a win
i think sophia play this right right
here
was the big one i think she should have
started with bishop e3 just to tickle
the queen before capturing
yeah but this last knight df6 i'm not so
sure about this don't you bring my queen
to a better square right now like rookie
two first
what do you do say what rook a2 check
rook a2 king f3
and i then i want to play bishop takes
g5 don't i go queen d8
i wanted to play
queen d8 is a good move i think you
could have taken directly i don't i
don't think we need to get fancy play
syndrome here okay seven bishop g5 let's
go down that line we went a little bit
because we
we yeah we
got a little lazy here let's actually
let's actually try to calculate this
right
oh we could play we could play
queen h4 protects f2 i think there's
more than one way to like not
yeah
that is not the checkmate so let's go
knight f5 knight f5 knight f5
let's we would wear this perpetual
please okay bishop c2 here just one
second guys bishop c2 yes yes yes why
can't i do that
that's very strong that's very strong
takes king d1 there's no more chucks and
that is mate on g7 remember that knight
importantly defends d4
so there is no queen d4
that's it that's just game right yeah we
do think that sophie in the time trouble
missed a win sorry i'm being told
there's another we have a winner in the
ladies yes the first uh result that we
actually have in the latest today uh
young rochelle wu did beat anne-marie
villa with the black pieces so rochelle
goes back to 50 after losing yesterday
anne-marie drops to -2 right
and speaking of that we have a guest in
our studio
thank you alejandro another player that
bounced back after a difficult defeat
against christopher you is brandon
jacobson brandon welcome to the show a
big victory for you how does that feel
yeah i mean i'm happy with the result
but certainly not happy with my play in
any of the games i mean
starting with my game against
christopher like
i overthought my my instincts like i
played this ridiculous movie takes v6
when of course in a bluetooth game i go
knight takes p6 and knight c4 and
probably hold
um
and even against mystery yesterday like
how did you deal with that loss that
must have been very disappointing for
you to start like that for sure um i
think i just tried to shake it off and
find my form
i did just come from two tournaments
back to back so maybe i felt like it was
you know first round nerves whatever it
is um
i tried to forget about it and try to
focus on the next game but then
yesterday too i mean i missed the
special takes h6 move and
would have basically been close to
winning again i didn't trust my
instincts and i'm really thinking the
problem is probably just maybe lack of
confidence maybe nerves i don't know
what what it is but um even today's game
like
it worked out and then but there are
definitely moments where i
could have played more precisely um
definitely back and forth but it did
seem like you got the best out of her
out of the opening did you expect her to
play this way uh yeah so before the game
i just looked at some lines um this
knight b2 rookie one is not the most
precise movie i think already black is
supposed to be quite comfortable after
knight g4 and king h8
um
and
yeah i went for this exchange stack but
um
perhaps we can have that on the board
right now
yeah so knight b2 is inaccurate white
chico h3 here just to avoid all this
knight g4 king h8
um and then
you know the game goes on h6 rookie h
normal italian
um but yeah knight bd2 knight g4
did you feel like she missed that like
what was the yeah i mean i think she
played knight b too quickly i i think
she was probably confusing the lions um
[Music]
but
yeah i assumed she wasn't familiar with
this knight she four kha idea because
she played knight b two maybe like 30
seconds and she was probably confusing
the move orders she forgot about three
yeah right and then because there are
some lines where you want to avoid h3
like black hasn't castled yet then you
want to avoid five right through because
then h6 and g5 is coming
so
yeah and then she thought for a long
time after f5
um
and i have a lot of options after knight
f1 like a lot of things look tempting
like even this knight back to f6
um but i figured after bishop e3 like
probably black is better i can go bishop
takes e3 and f takes c4 and like knight
h5 for example
and this was actually played at the top
level really most of the top level
players played knight f6
but the best way to continue is taking
and taking okay that's
so you found the best way over the board
yeah and the game i wasn't so sure um
but yeah the problem for what is you're
not exactly getting mated right away but
it's just sort of long term like she
takes f3 net h6
um like h6
oh
okay okay
well if knight f6 at that knight g3 and
then my knight can't go to h5 and then i
wasn't really sure to proceed i mean
that's probably good too
perhaps um h3
yeah maybe this was good too but it
should be three or something
um
things get to be double-edged right but
the point was that after knight h takes
like
let's say like this should be three i
don't know what the best move is but at
some point i'm just gonna go knight e7
and knight g6 and bring the knight to f4
and
it's not it's really uncomfortable for
white like you can go like rookie three
knight g3 bishop f1 try to hold on but
long term like you have no open files
for your rooks like even if you can
consolidate somehow like black code is
gonna have knight f7hg five ideas at the
right moment to great control over the
dark squares right so i figured this had
to have to be better for black um
yeah she took on g4
rook f8 yeah i had this interesting idea
rook f4 also after hc was probably
unnecessary but um
i thought it was kind of interesting but
i thought like
minimum white can take on f4 and go like
rook d2 you have e5
um then i can take on g4 i guess take on
g4 yeah if not h2 then maybe 95 and i
don't know
but okay sure that's probably good too
but i thought minimum like work d2 let's
say instead of knight h2
knight e5 and bishop we should be two
and if queen h4 then something like rook
d4 and just sack back and block my
bishop at some point um
so like we should be two let's say and
then
oh sorry you can't go bishop two here um
okay i guess getting my lines but
basically at some point maybe maybe you
should do now right yeah yeah maybe
that's knight
but you're still losing that g4
i don't know yeah there was some line
right where that just like worked before
and stacking perhaps that was okay yeah
that was at some point um before but
yeah rocket fails seemed simple enough
93
how did you assess the position yeah i
thought black was close to winning here
and then i played this ridiculous move
queen g5 i mean i totally missed rook f2
which was a really nice move like an id5
is i mean queen f6 and basically like up
a full tempo in the game lego queen f6
immediately
um i don't really see how she's stopping
like c6 and d5 and this looks almost
lost or white and we saw you on camera
at this point and you looked a bit bit
down a bit disappointed when you saw
this move look to f2 was that yeah the
way you felt i mean this is like maybe
the fifth time this tournament my
opponent plays the movie i didn't even
consider it was legal um and it just
felt like everything was going wrong and
i like i figured okay black of course
should still be better but like i get
rid of this g3 kg2 and all of a sudden
it's kind of a mess
you didn't want to see this
yeah i know for sure yeah i'm not even
sure if d5 was best i mean i can also
play slow with just going c6 first
um
i mean i suppose the position i got in
the game objectively was good for me the
whole time but like
it definitely got a bit messy at some
point um yeah c6 king g2 d5 maybe just
play like this a bit slower
right
um
let's say like
i think d5 was the right decision it was
the right decision it was the right
decision and
not the right decision for her was
actually to take on d5 after that it
seems that you're close to winning king
was supposed to be one of those times
where like when you start missing a lot
of moves you start to second-guess
everything that you're seeing so i
really
like the one good thing i did this game
was i was able to recognize that i
should just close my eyes and trust my
instincts and stop overthinking my moves
and then like starting around after d5
take bishop takes i started to play fast
and just sort of trust myself and i
think from there it went pretty smooth i
didn't really see any chances for her
after that brandon congratulations uh
big victory for you who do you have
tomorrow um david browski with the white
pieces uh double black so double black
that's a difficult game yeah well
congratulations and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you well done brandon
indeed i found i think he played very
well especially in the middle of queen
e6 i think
yeah queen h3 oh
i hate it when your opponent doesn't let
you get in your shots uh there's one
game left going and it's actually a very
very important game
uh
between mishra and awanda liang i mean
we're going to go
30 years
earlier and we were worried that the
bishop on
h2 would never get back into the game
is not getting back and
that's what a wonder felt as he's
currently i think really enjoying the
position he's got
essentially he's playing a piece up the
only way that white could possibly get
the bishop on g1 back into the game
involves him sacrificing the pawn with
f4 and then f3 now if christian sits
there and tells me the positions triple
zeros because white has a blockade
i mean i i'm going to throw in and throw
in my uh grand master title and say i
i'm not worthy of course it does right
christian you're better with black yes
you're not winning yet but you're
definitely better and i have a feeling
he's not going to be an easy defense for
a higher level but why only better i'd
be better isn't this night one day just
gonna find a really really good square
and i'm gonna be crying i think from a
practical perspective is close to
winning okay right for sure
my gosh i i mean it's really tough uh
being on panel with you guys because i
just think uh i think i don't i don't
get it i don't get it uh yasser let's
this one's gonna go forever i think
because well obviously what black is
better but uh we have plenty to play for
but we have a guest in studio all right
thank you alejandro we are with another
player that bounced back after a
difficult defeat earlier in the rounds
that is rochelle wu rochelle welcome
back to the show welcome back to st
louise how does it feel to be back over
over the board um it feels great i mean
like i've been playing chess over the
board so it's not like anything
completely new it's just like nice to be
back in st louis playing for a national
championship that's definitely a
different experience take us to uh
today's game
um
i'm like really surprised i just won
because i could
sworn that i was like
about to like lose right um
where did you feel like you're uh on the
back foot like i i don't hear that i was
like completely fine um
like for pawns it seems like i have some
threats
i was really happy to get the bishop
pair and
i i thought that like i would be able to
win this game eventually but like it
turned out a little bit harder than i
expected
um
so when did you feel you were worse or
like close to losing that happened like
later what was that at the beginning or
no that happens later later okay like
here
oh my god
i was like
we actually did not see this moment
i was like
how did no like i saw this happening
this coming um i just
i thought that she was gonna play like
knight takes g6 earlier instead of
bishop c4
and um
but then
before before like
before uh uh before bishop
knight takes g6 here and then and then
she goes bishop c4 that looks good yeah
i was like
um i thought i was just like okay i'm
just like completely screwed
but when she played
bishop c4 i was like wait i have
creature sex and then i completely
forgot about knight takes f7 immediately
oh my goodness and then like um we were
both in time pressure i just i didn't
really know what to play here so it
seems like queen b1 was a bad move but
what else could you have done bishop b3
was that the best yeah
no but i was like i'm fine i don't need
to do that i was just like
i'll just go like queen
um
and try
i completely forget about my piece on
a4
um i was
a little bit stressed
and i was like i completely forgot about
the piece but it was fine because wait
so you play queen c1 without seeing that
and then you just got lucky that it
doesn't work yeah oh my goodness
oh no
and then
i don't even know what just happened
queen e3
wow that is time pressure and a half wow
time travel makes fools of
all yeah that's a tough one
what a swing
what a swindle russian that's terrible
[Laughter]
i'm proud of you
very well
guys any questions
well done
go and enjoy this one but figure out
where you went wrong rochelle that was
wild wow
congratulations of victory guys
the win is a win and when does it win
it's a full point
bounces back to 50
good for her and we still have four
games in the ladies so we might as well
go through them but uh by the way i
think one of them is just that that that
that deadline i think alice is getting
made it yeah i think melissa's getting
mated right right it's the four rook
ending and her opponent
uh rue yang yen has just played the move
h6 which is just really a crushing move
because as soon as she gets to play rook
f7 it's just oh oh yeah terrible it's
just just a chat
i believe we have seen king before or
not yet
i don't think we've seen anything played
okay well i was before it makes the most
sense right because if you go king d3 at
least you get another check on third
rank not that it makes any difference no
but king before you guys say all these
things i didn't realize
go for it you can go king before you
could go forward
yeah getting made it i mean yeah like
that was the intention of course is like
i would be very happy to somehow
snake your way around right and uh
not take any pawns but just like
mermaid right right yeah even more
guys what's happening with that even
more made i like it six hours of
commentary i tell you
what's happening with alice lee guys
king d3
i like king d3 actually i i i because
rook check i got king d2 the problem is
[Laughter]
and she has played rook g8 inviting rook
f7 which will be played i assume
instantly exactly and then after king e8
i think it's time to
time to double on the seventh or at
least to offer a rook train yeah you
have to play rook f8 because your
kitchen is just too sad
but i mean i can even take and take and
i can play rook i can choose whatever
right exactly uh alice lee yeah the
start for alice actually saved two lost
positions she did but it doesn't seem
like she's gonna save a third one
exactly let's go again to our number
well coming into the round our uh
sophie who has started with two out of
two
uh can she make a three out of three
guys when we left it we thought that she
did not need to chase black's king into
essentially safety she played queen h5
to h6 king e8 bishop e3 on the board
that being said safety is a
strong word right like i mean okay i'm
threatening bishop takes b5 i'm
threatening knight takes d6 so i assume
i have to maintain
um
touch with both pawns uh pawns b5 and
pawns if i snake my way in with queen g7
i'm not a happy camper
good grief that's pretty bad yeah it
does rook a2 check does not help
at a certain moment bishop takes b i'm
just setting myself up for bishop
um
oops
i mean it still looks winning for white
it does it i mean
the desire you know run with the king
will only end up costing f7
that's in tears
yeah that's that looks winning to me i
think so three out of three yeah perhaps
not the most accurate way of doing
things
but it looks good enough to me and as we
told her she'll win a win is a win you
bet and this will be great for her three
out of three start in the u.s junior
girls absolutely fantastic for
jennifer you that would put a lot of
pressure on jennifer now we left it
and when we left it
uh
um jennifer virtually tripled
her rooks on the g file and yet the
position we're about to see somehow
white got in g4 like
what
what's going on what what what what why
did the pawn on a3 fall
i i
don't know like could i defend it
never
i was actually think the pawn the the a3
pawn was getting the a six right it was
a battering ram are we right right what
happened to that
uh okay okay
g4
what a shot knight to c4
the defensive pawn
is a pawn up well it's upon up not sure
how long she's going to be up well you
know h4 is very weak but you still have
to take it right yeah and by the way
somehow don't ask me how
this is about
whoa
this happened i think there was a lot of
time trouble moves that we did not see
not seeing and i think jennifer bested
her opponent in the time pressure
objectively how how do we feel about
this position
i'm happy to be here
i don't know if it's winning or not but
i think jennifer was actually on the
back foot yeah absolutely so
uh
winning
just happy that i i haven't lost
it feels like it right right
uh jumping christian uh was that that
seems like it was a lot of time trouble
that uh got ellen into trouble
absolutely maybe not trouble right now
it does seem like it's still within
margins of equality nevertheless it does
feel like it's only black that can play
for a victory in this one but now we see
this move is that a war
it's one of those moves that it works
brilliantly or it does not hurt at all
i think it works right
seven is just too strong right
with the f-pawn then i go queen descent
just a second just a second
aren't you inviting me to
at least equality no no no no no this
has to be a draw yes
it has to be it has to be a draw it has
to be a draw
like i wouldn't like jump out of my seat
to guarantee that's a draw so what would
you play i i insist d f e queen h5 why
why is this such a draw
he's going to win h5 what if he takes f4
he takes a five is that engagement draw
i don't know
king f6 i gained a tempo in the bishop i
protect my pawn
it has to be a draw
he's guaranteed all right let's go by
the way i i've noticed i'm pretty tired
i was thinking it was the right colored
knight for the rook
[Laughter]
the right colored knight wait a second
that's how it works i don't even know
what that's nice
uh we got the wrong colored bishop
right that's why he gets
the uh
big bucks as the national world champion
we had that dinner that conversation
last night at dinner i was saying to rex
that you guys had won the national
championships
that's great you said well the world
championship yes sir and it was like oh
that sounded more convincing oh we want
that one too that's what i mean
nice nice nice uh well we'll see uh e4
on the board uh besides
rushing into things
um
if black could black play b5 and just i
don't know try to push her pawn what is
black what is white threatening that's
what my question really was all about i
assume you're going to take this
on d5 and maybe my king
[Music]
cannot it's kind of a weird position
because the moment
the queen activates yeah it activates
with a lot of strength but right for the
time being they're kind of caged in you
can play mutually literally right yeah
like if you buy queen f1 i might take
advantage of this opportunity to play
either queen f savage yeah but i think
queen g is too strong instead of queen
f1 okay i think you you start running
into problems
with bishop e5 chat bishop e5 or queen
g5 or something yeah
oh my gosh which means i'm probably
gonna have to step back
passively um
must be theater if black is going to try
to play for a win in this game christian
uh
give jennifer some tips how is she
supposed to do it if no
as
we already looked at and then queen h5
probably that's the best attempt okay
but
if i try to keep the position other i
have other ideas that i want to
implement after queen to h5 i don't have
to take on f5 but what does the engine
say of that end game i'm just curious uh
it's it's equal you let it think for a
little bit and it seems 0.2 yes at the
beginning it does give black some uh a
bit of an edge but after that it's just
looks to be
easy
that's definitely something you can play
but i don't know if it was enough
wow barely not okay uh sorry i i just
want to check in on the alice
now alice is boston all this is in
trouble and what about talia
talia is
winning completely winning another
the training it's so good it's so good i
love it when they spread their rings um
and
it's pretty good and that's a huge pond
it's like it's it's not just a material
advantage
it's this uh it's a great passer uh for
tell you this is done
this is done done and does that right
right
five i think you just push the f bone
next yeah yep yeah any rook check you
can
no this is this is i think this is too
easy okay fair enough but for talia what
a great story right a victory means that
she's still within half a point
of the leader and we might have a clash
without an important clash between these
two players down the line i'm actually
going to check out when they yeah that's
uh something to look forward to we're
expecting talia to play the move f4 f5
in order just to give her uh king more
breathing square
and to kick out the opponent king right
so you take on f5 i can go rook f3 rook
f2 exactly exactly so
all right and just a second there was
another uh game there zoe
second no that that was that was the
alice lee game sorry
and this is
all of them
we've got we've got through all of them
and bishop e3 queen a6
all on the board we like this creepy
crawly move
queen g7 well we like the creepy crawly
against uh
the queen bee b8 i gotta make sure that
rook d3 doesn't work
because then
i do have
queen a3 to try to just okay well let's
put it on the board right
so
if you don't play rook takes d3
you're kind of like stuck for a move
your knights can't you can't move
anything but you're not in time i mean
rook takes d3 i take back
christian you need insight
jack you know
you're not in time to put a queen on the
light squares yeah i would love to give
a check from c2 if possible fortunately
that's not how the queen moves so
is knight takes d3 a decisive threat
then like if i i don't know if i go
let's say i think knight takes d6 is big
yes it's just
well like take with a queen and then you
cannot play because
yes that's pretty yeah so i guess we
should look at queen takes before right
i mean we played queen b3 but why not
queen takes before okay
we're not even not material
so now the question
is can i go from behind and create some
problems
okay
so what do you like queen h
yes
king has to go and you mean queen to b
eight yes let's go on the other side
what do you know
though
i don't get it you're no longer tethered
to the knight so knight takes e4 and you
will like queen c4 king e1
am i escaping or am i escaping per pets
i'm not sure i don't see how you're
escaping them
this looks like a pet to me
prepared
[Laughter]
okay so maybe this mcqueen a6
uh by gracie is setting up a very nice
cheapo if she can rescue herself with
rook takes d3
you know
she's going to try that's that's a
that's a good move
i think so can i
do something for sophie's position here
let's say i just make a instead of the
move queen g7 just a little bit
yeah f3
does that make a a diff
because rook takes d3
it's not really up material right i
could keep my queen somehow
in this case
can i somehow
like make a b line to safety
you definitely can
with the pawn on e4 protected thanks to
the pawn on f3
maybe
i don't fall for an immediate perpetual
and i have some
chances to win
what do you think of
or
you think she should not play rook takes
d3 maybe two rook a2 king f1
let's head for the hills f1 all right so
i can play queen a4 now right
queen a4
because bishop takes b5 queen takes b5
is a counter check
right
so you don't have an idea it takes two
you can start with knight d6 but then i
go king
be careful don't go
to d7 not the d7 so i have to go to e7
right
so i slurped the pawn for free that's
okay now i run now i go king d7
but
how happy am i to have an extra pawn in
the pockets i don't know queen c2 i'm
well creeping in also you can get take
another one no i i don't i don't
i don't want to
die with a full tummy
knight
g3 you've got all right let's set up
that
battery on the first round quickly one
rook a1
and rook a1
now i have to make room for my king
so how do you do it because um
it does seem like you're losing one of
the bishops right yeah that's me
that's not what i bargained for when i
played f2 f3 that wasn't part of the
program yeah so f3
uh rook jack king the idea is good guys
so you do want to make some space for
your king okay but check this out not f3
g4
okay g4 g4 in order to go king f3 king
g2 hide it yes
wow
that's a
that's a move
not an easy one though
not an easy one just played something
else
knight g7 check
okay but how does that help what if i
just simply go back to e7 i don't think
you want to go back to e7 right out of
all places the natural one i think it
was d7 but why night i like the knight
on f5 what knight she's seven
i think she wants to go knight to h5
ah actually the seven at h5 is an issue
i think that's what she wants to do okay
right okay
she's thinking that she still has king
f3 in a lot of cases so even if you
somehow managed to get the bishop on d3
if i managed to take on f6 and uh invade
with my queen then you're in trouble so
i think
you might be losing this one but let's
go to e7 okay
knight d7 king e7
it looks counterintuitive to encourage
bishop takes g5 but okay or to allow the
knight to return with chuck um
let me take a pawn i'm a pawn grubber
okay that's fine so let's take on g5 now
even though i'm not 100 sure if i want
to take and rook a2
rook a2 or do you hide with the king is
the question i was hoping queen a3
to hide i i don't know i don't know
can i no you got rook too i mean i take
on d3
i mean i take your bishop all i wanted
to do is get a safe king we're not even
on material like knight f5 comes and i
get it but the game continues right
absolutely yeah yeah how many pounds for
the exchange i saw rook f2 and i stopped
wow wow
guys still a fight there for first place
big fight sophie morris tries to break
through gracie's strong defenses this is
a game that will keep us intrigued for a
while we're going to take a short break
as we let some of these games wind down
to their final time pressure don't go
anywhere we'll be back in a few minutes
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the
championships here in st louis we have
the juniors the junior girls and the
senior and in round number three we
already have all of the games of the
seniors done yeah we have one standings
there but in the juniors and in the
junior girls we still have a lot of
fights ahead of us absolutely there you
see the playing hall i think that's a
wonder
i wonder
at the very bottom there he's and this
one just finished but we did call this a
while ago riyan yan as you can see
they're one of the participants of the
american cup 2022 did put the finishing
touches in a masterful game against
alice lee taking advantage of superior
piss activity from very beginning to
very end never let go of it i have to
say this was a very impressive game by
really young uh it's so hard to keep
control drew out
normally you get a slip and at the very
end it was all about the fact that
white's rooks
are just so powerful it there was
nothing that alice could do to save the
game and in the final position
well i was just about to say the king is
finding a sanctuary that's a lot of
false yeah and it's a lot of ponds
another one that is about to finish is
the game of a wonder versus abhimani so
let's take a look at that one because
abimanu well unfortunately
a wonder managed to break through he did
yes he did well it was always
mishra the bishop on g1 we just thought
was the most
unhappy
piece
and that's still the case
now down to his last 50 seconds is
abhimanyu right now with a losing
position exactly yeah this is queen b
three straight
wow queen d3 i mean we can even start
thinking of exchanging the queens
i was
exchanging like knight c1 and
uh exchanging the queens like f4 knight
c1 and queen d3
or going to f4 maybe you can also i
think you're just choosing your way of
winning but sorry i was just take on f2
yeah that's what i was thinking too can
i do a um
a capture because i've got this move
queen d3 you have to go queen c2 i guess
no
but crazy two is just dead then i
definitely take on d3 this is uh
this is this is easy mate
oh but also queen c2 i go queen g3
i go from the other side no this is over
knight xf2 is uh is pretty much over
and you go from the other side
and you get in a check and then you take
yes
and i think you're getting checkmated
yeah just over clear so we are expecting
uh
bless you
a winder
a wonder a one a wonder liang uh to play
knight takes f2 and i have to say guys
this was a very nicely played game it
was wonderful very patient also it felt
like it wasn't making any progress but
he just went around and around and
around right until eventually i'll be
mine you cracked and we've seen this
idea that players crack under pressure
after a very long
suffering which is exactly what happened
in this game
and kudos to a wonder it's an important
bounce back for him absolutely and
should he win this game that will be our
third victory in the juniors uh with two
draws in this the third round right now
we have two victory two victors and two
draws in the juniors and again i just
want to go to the game of sophie because
how big is that result uh
with
um
two and a half points
for the ladies talia
thank you yes we think talia is winning
by the way i don't think she's actually
won the game
yet
yeah but she was several pawns up she's
two pawns up in a you know i mean it's
one it's just okay yeah so talia will be
at two and a half and she'll be keeping
a careful eye on the sophie game against
gracie and in a real turn off event uh
we actually left off the game between
ellen wang and jennifer yu draw we
thought it was a drawing within the
drawing margin
but uh
she's having some problems
did play a lot of weird moves
and while we were coming back on
commentary we did see that the table
base
announces this as a win for black oh you
just simply give up the knight king d5
is coming and you cannot stop it exactly
yeah yeah the kg4 just king d5 the the
thing that is very strange that uh the
reason that i think this is losing for
white if you go down a couple of moves
i mean there's nothing i mean there's
nothing to calculate here i mean if you
go the other way oh i'm sorry uh like
why how white lost this
because this move bishop h6 with the
idea of bishop f8
seems very very slow
i thought d5 was kind of automatic
yeah d5 here yes yeah you take and i go
d6 yes and then i have to come back to
stop the pawn but you know you're so
slow here exactly right right and you're
not defending h4 with the knight you're
defending it with the king which is no
progress
yeah exactly
you could put the knight on d7 but
you're not protecting h4
okay so instead she
but boy
it's an easy
trap to fall for because now the knight
is actually perfect perfect perfect it
could not be better yeah yeah you're
defending h4 if you ever go king g4
takes f5
the h-pawn will be released and that's
exactly what we're seeing
king d5 we think jennifer's going to win
this game wow what a turnaround but we
have a special guest in studio let's
take christian another uh breakthrough a
player in this round rue yang yen with a
huge victory against atleast lee rue
yang first of all welcome back to the
show what are your first
feelings after this big victory uh it
feels pretty good because because i
because i choked like a really good
position last round so it feels good to
like you know like win
what was the strategy you were playing
with the white pieces against one of the
toughest competitors in this tournament
and you know alice quite well how did
you approach this game uh i i didn't
like really like prep that much i just
like looked through my lines and you
know i just like yeah just i just like
went with the flow i just wanted to go
with the flow and play the game let's
take a look at the game how did you uh
feel the opening went
were you happy with the outcome uh yeah
and but like after like like in the
middle of the opening i was like pretty
confused like what i was supposed to do
so like i kind of thought for a long
time but i like this like rook f1 f4
idea um i didn't like i didn't want to
like trade the bishops because because
like i'm playing like like pressure
position and
um
um
yeah
f4 and and this was a moment that kind
of confused us a little bit and here on
the panel
the two guys on the other side of
this board uh we're saying that black is
actually better
how did you assess this end game uh and
the engine was saying that white is
better by the way just to give you uh
an insight but i also felt like black
should be more or less fine how did you
assess it yeah i thought black was fine
but i thought um because like if i could
like push like d4 and e5 or something i
would be okay and her dark squares are
kind of
weird i guess
and i could pressure f7 pawn
so yeah well you definitely uh had the
more accurate assessments
of at this position because it was
indeed much better for white for that
particular reason the fact that you're
starting to push your central majority
as you did in the game
so
what was the next critical moment in
your opinion uh i don't know maybe
around here yes because like she traded
off my good night but um but i kind of
realized like at first i was like out i
was kind of like you know iffy about
this position but but i kind of realized
that like
um like she can't really do anything
and like i could just like pressure her
and you know like maybe like treat all
the bishops or like d4 and b4 and then
like
uh i don't know like i could like i
could always like push and she has to
like defend it so
it's like the f5 is really
pleasant for you yes yeah so you feel
like you have pretty decent chances of
winning right yeah
and then
when did you feel like the critical
moment came that gave you a winning
point yeah after like rookie a um africa
bishop
like maybe like h4 wasn't that good like
i could have done like bishop c4
immediately mm-hmm but like he just like
i just like didn't like i don't know
like i i just like i just like wanted to
like hold the position to like move 40
and yeah improve the position to the
maximum why not
why not and it did feel like you're
breaking through right now creating
another one
king e7 wasn't good i think what else
could she have but did she really have
like anything else to do
like d7 maybe yeah
maybe like b7 but like
i don't know i have like g5 h5 or like
like rook f7 stuff
yeah
but i i feel like rook g7 i feel like
she was gonna try to go like king e7 and
try to hold the position and like rook
ba try to create counter play on the
queen side but this doesn't but like i
kind of saw this h5 idea
so yeah
royang a big victory uh for you it
almost feels like you're so young yet it
feels like you're one of the most
experienced players on this roster are
you going to try to go for a victory in
this event yeah
this is the big plan guys any questions
no our congratulations uh just that you
played
with such control and you kept
alice essentially out of the game we
thought this was a very well played game
uh
keep it up uh keep your success going
well done
well thank you riyang and let's update
the boards that we have in the junior
girls because two huge moves in the game
of sophie and gracie and i have to say
we saw the exchange section did you see
the exchange sacrifice
more suzuki prasanna let's see if we can
get that board out oops yeah it was
right here yeah yeah so this is just
make sense how it makes sense you defend
the knight king e2 i didn't like this
move because queen a2 queen c4 but
yeah it is what it is
black played knight takes e4
whoops
that's a piece
what am i missing you're not missing
anything she just uh it's over queen
takes h7 and uh it feels like it's so
weird we thought the knight was tethered
to
the other one the other one and unless
there's
that's one chest i go to f3 and then
yeah i mean
i guess you have to go queen c2 is that
it
what is
it you say that bishop g5 uh it's a
really bad move
oh yeah
good morning
it's been a long day yes
the amazing thing has been uh since ever
since you left this man we've had these
long long long long
candidates yeah candidates man we got uh
we got guys
i wonder i wonder i wonder i wonder i
wonder oh my goodness what happened
what
what
what
oh my goodness
what
hold on hold on i'm not up with uh oh
you guys christian bamboozled us he
bamboozled us
all the wonder
his lion was wrong and abby monu has
refuted it over the board guys queen g3
didn't work at all oh
no
okay just a second just queen takes we
left it here and we thought knight takes
f2 was done and i'm done
keep going keep going
queen c2 we saw this move and we
expected bishop takes oh my god and then
we saw check
king here check
king here and please sign my score
sheets
that was the line that a wonder oh this
is a tragedy guys this is a tragedy
queen takes what is your king doing on
a7
oh my god what a move queen takes f2
this is the cold shower this is such
a disaster
what a disaster for a wonder and again
he comes in as our highest rated seed
he's thinking i got a ticket to the u.s
championship all i got to do is get
beat my junior rifles queen takes f2
and i'll wait for the uh
amish is under a minute can we can we
get our analysis board so we can there
we go but we'll keep it queen takes f2
bishop takes f2
check
the king had to move and now
let's go back to the the board itself
the uh bird view because of that 40
seconds what's what's the situation 56
seconds against 33 minutes my goodness
but what is the actual evaluation of
this endgame i mean white's up a piece
right for a pawn
the pawns on the kings that is should be
complete
because i've got bishop c8
i i first want to see the move f3 f2 but
i don't know i'm not going to do it i'll
just take
i just think i was about to say
why do i need to force f2 but then i
take shouldn't i have just started with
the move bishop c8 but then well how do
you make progress
it's the wrong colored bishop huh
well there are some chances right that i
go c5 c4 i take on a5 i take on yeah
what do you think something i think no
but i throw c5 in before
okay okay okay so i take take
so bishop c8 i think i go c5 bishop c8
you think you go c5 but then i get to
keep this bar as soon as you play c5 i
go here
and here but you and then what but yes
sir you can go like that from d1
you can do it from d1 from d1 which is
why that's why he played bishop g4 he
played bishop g4 i like doing it from d1
a lot more okay
fair so now you can go king g2 or bishop
d1 first
and then wait until the king has to move
away from a5 exactly and then we go back
to e2 and pick up all the pawns pick the
pawn yes oh my gosh so
we think it's winning thanks to bishop
to d1 i don't guarantee it though
it doesn't come with a warranty
oh but for a wonder
what a shock disaster what a shock he
had done everything he had done
everything beautifully he had his
opponent yes in his crosshairs he was
just about to it was over right it was
over guys there was more than one way to
skin that cat
and
he chose the one that didn't work
pita is calling you cannot skin the cat
he cannot skin the cat and the wonder
suffering at the board
look at his expression i mean he's he
had a loss
i mean this is borderline just
crying time for a one right really does
feel like it because he could crash to
minus two minus two
and this one is oh
guys no this is johnny for you pardon me
jennifer you won against ellen wang as
you can see those pawns
that's a huge victory for her
wow she was not doing well in this event
and she was not doing well today in this
game today right
huge bounce back for jennifer you and
she's back in the mix jennifer you wins
against ellen wang actually overtakes
her opponents now sitting with two
points we expect her to still be a full
point behind sophie morris but at least
that's a catchable distance oh
definitely
wow uh just
yeah we're stunned by stunt these
turnarounds both in the jennifer you
game but especially a wonder uh liang as
a wonder fell for
the problem for black is i think they're
kind of
such a sense so you're going to win a
tempo at some point right exactly
and uh be mine you're making sure of his
moves down to those last 35 seconds
remember he does have increment he gets
30 seconds per move right he needs to
make sure that he takes these spawns at
the appropriate moment he could start
with bishop e2 but bishop d1 is just
better technique it allows him to win
this is a heartbreaking swindle yes i
haven't seen a swiddle this hard in a
while yeah queen takes f2
f2 is just such a from plus 10 plus
infinity probably you're just simply
going to checkmate your opponent
to minus 4
in one move yeah i mean this is
resignable then if if if mine you
actually had more time
yeah then it would be resignable
it's only the time
pressure
that's stopping
uh uh
b6 and right now you just have to lose a
couple of tempes yeah you go bishop two
two or whatever you you
you wait for black to run out of moves
exactly and they will go king to a6 and
yeah maybe we can pan out to see a
wonder leaning back in his chair
i mean i i think he's just in shock
devastated actually i would be
devastated deficient right now but you
can't
think about this you can't explain this
feeling it's something that you feel as
a chess player has happened to every
single child all the blood rushes it
simultaneously rushes out of your
face and you feel cold yeah and then it
rushes back in and you feel hot
it's horrible it really is
king a-6 and i think it's time i think
it's time to collect
it's just a mix of feelings right you
feel
ashamed of what you just
angry
oh angry and and you
the worst part is you still aren't sure
if you're lost
so like part of you still trying to tell
you to calculate right figure out if you
can actually save the end game to save
yourself yeah
now bishop to d3 and start picking up
horns and then you calculate you go
through the same seven stages of grief
but in like one second
right
oh it tastes inferno yeah
right yeah yeah but this is too easy you
just pick up every pawn exactly and plus
you get to play c4
yeah that's the thing right you don't
even get any no nothing nothing nothing
you don't even get a pretty no nothing
not even the two connected past pawns
maybe you can queen one right nope
nothing this desire to save uh the
impossible king takes g3
king takes a4
king takes f2
king b3 c4 c4 king c3 king e3 it's just
game over
right there's just not even a little
chance
what eight wow guys i i i'm just so
speechless i have not seen a turnaround
of this magnitude in a game between two
grand masters yep in a long in a while
well not that i've casted chris
christian said you went from plus ten to
minus four but it's not even about that
it was mishra who only had seconds on
his clock
a wonder
had 30 minutes right add that to the mix
of how
bad his position c4 stopping b5 king
goes to e3 to shoulder the king bishop
to f1 e5 and this is it there's more
than one way to win this one it is time
to resign after that
it it's hard
i've i've had my howlers i really have
had
my followers but
i'm really thinking where i threw away a
draw
if you know what i'm saying right
i've been worse i've been worse maybe i
could save the game and i made a move
that
i thought i was losing anyway
and actually i had more chances more
resources than i thought
and i lost the game
but
going from a completely overwhelming
victory to a loss
what that's
i can't it doesn't come
immediately to mine it's hard to find
one of those yeah blundering half a
point happens oh my gosh look at him it
it does happen half a point happens all
the time but blundering a full point
he's devastated
wow
what a blow
what a blow
this just kills your whole tournament i
know a game like this just finishes your
whole tournament exactly and he's
i know
that's the amazing the rating favorite
of the event starts with half out of
three well maxim delugey just came on
the show and he said you know like he
played in the us senior where he scored
like
a half out of six but then he won his
last three games but half out of six
guys one second mishra just made his
move with like three seconds ice cream
so how do you win this one i think what
do you mean
it's just winning
e5 no no but that's not clear because
that's the wrong caller it doesn't
matter this guys
the king's too far away yeah okay i take
on e5 and how do you get e4 you just
just and then i go b5 yeah yeah you take
that
take twice
you can
wonder
it's by the way he's playing because he
knows he's got only one chance
and that's the clock
so then you put the bishop on the a2 g8
diagonal yeah yeah
the the king comes nowhere near yeah the
the squares he needs to be exactly
by the way i had seen a
game annotated by mishra
and his annotations to an ending were
extraordinarily good
and it seemed to me that
somebody has worked with his in-game
technique he knows his endgames i was
impressed
uh by his endgame knowledge
who does he work with
mishra i mean i don't know actually i
know that he's part of the kasparov
chess foundation
in the the all-star and the all-star
young australian wonders too i wonder
what's actually he's an alum of the he's
a little um
he's too old now yes sir
he's in college he's in sophomore we
forgot about him yeah yeah yeah the
talent uh becomes an adult yeah i get it
it happens to all of you are we
expecting king f5 i know i wonder since
he was like 10.
remarkable yeah now he's just too old
for the
foundation i mean i worked i worked with
a wonder i think in like 2012
really yeah
youth championships i might have been
jeffrey's first defeated gm
back in dallas when he was like seven
[Laughter]
jeffrey john yeah jeffrey johnson you
created the monster oh man you
encouraged him to continue the plane
we're holding you accountable christian
i feel old
we should
i remember jeffrey visiting a summer
camp that i did
and he was just
he was just wonderfully enthusiastic
about everything he would just go uh
from one camper to the
other one to play blitz want to play
blitz
i'm ready to play blitz
i don't think there's any need to touch
the spawn on b5 right
at the moment
no i don't think so i think i could just
take another mistake right and g5 and
push it yeah
i think you have to take on c4 after
yeah takes g5 and he's going for the g5
pawn i think yeah
yeah that's probably the cleanest
by the way his clock tight i mean i
think he's making his moves in the
appropriate yeah he has 20 seconds
yeah yeah but he's not really building
up much time
if you take on c4 do you take back or do
you go bishop b4
i think you take back
just so the king doesn't i think the
bishop is equally good at c4 as well as
e4 but you're right i mean you you may
stop and think about well maybe i could
put my bishop on e4 but i would just
take the pawn take the pawn back yeah
the first time he's almost pre-moved
that that was that came pretty fast yeah
but this one is unstoppable though h3 is
going yeah by the way because you're
covering g8 you're not making it to the
corner right now into the corner yeah i
think
the bishop patrols
yeah there it is he resigns he resigns
it's over
wow he
is going to shoot out the door
and uh christian if you could get a
wonderful
poster interview
don't be so cruel i don't think so no i
he's doing the most gentlemanly thing
he's setting up his pieces even he's
signed the score sheets he's doing what
he needs to do but man does he want to
get out of there right and we cannot
blame him no what a turnaround of events
for him this was this went from a
brilliancy to a disaster
and when we talk about the cruelty of
chess guys this is this is it in all of
its glory
wow we've all been there at some point
yeah we have all been burned like this
but man this was this was hard to watch
it really was fortunately we have a
guest so we get to uh recover ourselves
uh over to you christian i'm here with
jennifer you the rating favorite coming
into this event jennifer a team start
but finally you broke through how does
that feel
um it feels pretty good honestly i don't
know if
this game probably wasn't the um
the best
way to
see that but um
i am not exactly sure like what the
evaluation was throughout the game but
it was definitely really it felt like
she was playing really well at the
beginning especially in the opening
phase did you feel that way
yeah i mean the thing is um i feel like
in some way in a weird way i do have a
weird disadvantage where i'm trying to
play for a win and i don't think all my
opponents are doing the same thing so
when you know when i'm playing the
exchange law of black it's like i have
to do something and if that means doing
something dubious maybe
um if i get chances
i think yeah she played pretty well for
a while and then at some point like near
time control i got some chances and then
i think we left it somewhere around
after bishop to g4 when you started
storming on on the king side with h4 g4
and then she offered this trade with the
bishops on g4
and then he took
bishop to d3 was a move that was played
before but he took on g4 how did you
assess the position at this
point uh well honestly i didn't really
see if i had anything um but
you know it's a chance right so that's
just what i was going for
um
because i feel like if she played like
like she did pretty well in the game i
didn't really get anything and it was
only
like yeah like
maybe um when she started letting my
knight go like a5 then i was probably
doing okay but
um
yeah like for a while here i was just
kind of stuck
and then you had this opportunity to go
rook to g3 did you consider this at all
yeah i spent a bit of time here because
i really wanted to make this move work
i'm not sure does it work or i don't
know only for equality i think yeah
because these i like i just couldn't get
take to work um queen takes f3 and then
um well i think can you play queen takes
h4 i think queen takes h4 was the most
yeah and then i just see like y always
has a perpetual somewhere yes um and
yeah just it wasn't just it wasn't
enough but i was really trying to make
it work here with like f4 or whatever
like instead of queen takes f3 different
ideas but
so your mindset at this point was that
you're playing for a win yeah i mean
that was for an entire game but you know
the opening made it a lot more difficult
and uh you decided to go rook to d7
and then she gave you some chances
when you guys entered this end game
let's go to that point
it seemed like things were simplifying
did you still uh harbor any
uh hopes at this point i mean here i
thought it was um
it's pretty like she could definitely
play
for uh simplify the position simplifying
maybe it draws pretty easy but then we
got into this nine bishop end game and
um somehow like white just doesn't
really have that many moves
right the way she continued i'm not
there's probably yeah maybe that's a
better defense but i think d5 and d6
and then just try to focus on capturing
the pawn on h4 yeah that was
key
so what do you think she missed did she
uh perhaps miss that she you can just
leave the knight on f5 unattended
i think she missed 93 93 um because it's
like you're thinking you can take that 5
the whole time
that makes sense
so here if she plays king to h3
is that still a draw
looking to h3 b4
even if it is a draw it's going to be
very close right because yeah she has to
go bishop to c1 yeah this is not a
pretty defense for white
this is not i wasn't sure like i saw
this briefly and i couldn't exactly tell
this when you're not because i was like
if the king gets the ct really quickly
cool whoa jennifer uh a big victory for
you
did you feel like you dust off your
shoulders the first three rounds i mean
yeah it's good to just get it out of the
way because
i think i um i had a really good
position my first two games and i was
also pushing for both of them and kind
of the same thing
um
kind of like a draw which like equalish
opening and i just tried really hard to
create something and then i just kept
choking in the end so i was like you
know um i'm gonna just keep trying this
game
guys any questions uh just our
congratulations jennifer keep it up but
you need those wins
yeah definitely a long fight as we have
one game remaining actually in the u.s
junior girls okay surprising
our
tournament uh leader in fact no they're
actually still playing
uh
unfortunately for black let's see a lot
of the results as they've been coming in
alejandro sure talia cervantes won
against zoe tank quite a while ago two
and a half points for her means that we
expect her to be trailing the leader by
only half a point and this one which was
the heartbreak of the year
huge turnover look at the decade
abimenum mishra won against awander
liang from a totally lost position
tricked his opponent in time not even
time pressure
it's hard to talk about it
it's tough it's tough stuff and but this
result was just crazy it was crazy by
the way just mentioning that in the
ladies uh section we do have four out of
four in terms of decisive games so far
and it seems to me it might be five out
of five hundred percent five out of five
right this pawn on
six about to be a queen exactly exactly
and a great result for sophie who
perhaps didn't convert
exactly the way that we wanted her to
but it was good enough and
she with this win
i'm not really sure why we're playing
this we're going to see queen to g1
queen the g1 blocking the check with
this widget
three out of three what a dream start
for this player yeah
no three out of three
you know it feels really really good you
could play in the national championships
you get your first victory and you think
to yourself
oh man that was just okay that that's
the monkey off my shoulders you know
like at least i got one win
uh you go three out of three and your
ambition is just soaring through the
roof you just go okay i'm supposed to
win this event aren't i yeah queen c3
that's just pickling the pawn on h3
right now she's playing cheapos she's
played some good players in the in the
raiding list she didn't feed rochelle
and that has to put huge amount of wind
behind your sails because that's one of
the top rated players one of the
talented players everybody's talking
about yep and you beat her up exactly uh
by the way this is a mass
you play g7 and you think okay why don't
you resign
it's a draw on the spot that would be a
terrible blunder to advance your pawn
and allow queen takes h3 check okay so
what's the best move just king h2 is i
have queen g4 queen somewhere queen g4
a4 and then hide the king to h4a yes
exactly that was exactly my
my thinking there must be a lot of ways
to do this but protect upon hc maybe
queen g3 i like queen g4 it has
everything protected right she's moving
for the knight
whoa
wait a minute this allows queen f3 check
queen f3 why are you doing this why did
you make it difficult for yourself good
winning anyway
i mean i'm sure everything should be
within gg4 was just like okay that's it
we can sign the score sheets and go to
dinner this is not
as easy as it should be guys i think the
players want us going to dinner
i noticed that about the players this
tournament guys she missed queen i don't
like they don't like us they're having
dinner
they just skip today no they just no no
hours for us to have them
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah no i get that
no i mean commentators it's worse job
man it's just terrible if if i play
queen f3 and queen g2 you probably have
to go queen jutu right
what
i was gonna go no i was gonna go knight
queen takes h3 and then queen h2 also
knight g2 maybe i can consider queen g3
queen g3 is a nasty move but no no no no
no i've got queen c one check
you're happy
sorry uh let me just put that once again
on the board because what i can do
thereafter
is immediately post my queen on h6 and
keep my cheap on so but that's nice
thank you
but it's a very awkward way of play i
mean again right here the very very
simplest was just go clean up
any checks you don't even have to worry
about all you've got to do just run
exactly let's run just all right guys
but yes she's about to play queen g2 did
she calculate this one precisely is this
winning i guess she did yes yes because
she has queen g1 at the end so g7 queen
c1 queen g1
queen g2 what am i well i i thought
knight g2 won just a second queen g
you're saying queen g2 wins how's it win
quinton
f4 g7 queen c wanna have to give queen c
queen g one no g one queen h6
i was good but i have two queens i don't
care how many hours you have babies
oh my goodness she resigned
she resigned in a drawn position
guys it was a draw yes of course it was
a draw
oh my goodness she resigned in a draw
position i've actually seen that from a
problem
wait let me get this straight she played
down a piece for like 30 moves exactly
and when it's finally a draw she
resigned what a route guys
a wonder now
sophie maurice suzuki winning we had a
wonder we have sophie and we had
jennifer
uh once again we got to toss it to
christian so we get that chance to
recover he's got a guess
[Laughter]
wow well first of all talia i mean she's
one of your main competitors
what what do you make of that i mean
that's that's great for her i mean i
remember last year i actually saved
something like as bizarre as this if not
worse so against her like i managed to
make a draw
but yeah that's crazy i mean you're
still half a point behind a great
victory for you today yesterday even
with jennifer you have some chances
unfortunately you were also a little bit
worse at what point how
did you feel about that game
um
i was a bit worried because
it's a very simple end game but i tend
to mess it up
but thankfully everything turned out
well i made a weird maneuver with my
bishop it ended up doing nothing on a4
but after we traded everything off and
we just got into a rook in game it was
just a very clear draw so i was content
with my result yesterday and today i'm
also
let's take a look at today's game let's
take a look at today's game take us
through the critical moments it felt
like you got a really good position out
of the opening did you feel that way as
well it felt like so um i i feel like i
kind of forced her to put the bishop on
d4 because otherwise there were some
tactics i don't know if they worked
entirely but after
knight of six let's say i was
considering e5
and the thing about the four pawns is i
always have funny ideas so the knight
goes away to play knight h7 yeah
so if knight h5 knight takes h7 right i
am not sure i'm not sure if everything
works out
um i mean here i i do think it works out
here it works yeah
but it's like take six knight d7 i
wasn't super sure but i mean it still
looked nice and i was probably gonna go
for it
so
yeah
looks compelling yeah it looks it looks
quite nice
yeah so she had to play bishop d4 and i
felt like here
okay the bishop is stuck only four so i
can always take it and i'll have the
bishop player control of dark squares
but it was never clear if i should take
it or not because then the knight on d4
is very strong and i have a lot of
weaknesses in the a8h1 diagonal
and then
you
let's keep going right so here i'm just
making like consolidating moves i'm not
allowing either b5 or d5 i feel like
that's kind of my main main
focus right now in the position
and when she went knight f5 i think
which she was getting low on time
but here i felt fine because i have the
better pawn structure so
i thought that my moves now were
relatively obvious and i think she had
like
three two minutes so
um it'll felt quite natural i'm not sure
if i should have allowed b5 but i
thought opening the position would be
okay
since she's slow on time and d6 still
weak e6 this week
and
it's kind of like the pieces are tied up
and eventually
after some moving around
um yeah just making the pieces better
after h6 now i have the squing g4 now
you have some more weaknesses to deal
with very nice and yeah after this i
went upon and i got into a winning end
game but suddenly
it took so it took so long for me to win
um
probably i didn't play the west
maybe maybe yasser and alejandro were
bursting me out you played well enough
good job
you did good you did it
you got good enough is good enough so
yeah um eventually here i guess we just
started trading everything off and
coupons is two pounds yeah
i have two so i wasn't worried yeah yeah
great victory for you uh talia
who do you have tomorrow
i don't know actually i think i have
rochelle
rochelle who is coming off victory as
well well talia congratulations once
again a blazing hot start in the first
three rounds keep it up thank you nicely
done talia seriously uh good control
gate right i always felt that she had
the upper hand
and she didn't really ever allow her
opponent back in once she started
winning the pawns boy then it was good
but this is the difficulty that we've
seen in chess and we've seen it already
in the games today it's so hard to win
control from start to finish very
difficult but kudos to talia and tori
young that also did the same thing today
against alice lee well let's take a look
at all of our standings as a round three
was won for the record books this is
alejandro i need some recovery
this is an
unreal round i don't think i've seen a
round like this wow in a long time
sophie morris suzuki is the leader of
the girls junior championship with a
perfect three out of three because her
opponent resigned in a drawn position
aleandro oh my god
yes cervantes is two and a half out of
three and jenny for you and riyan now
joining her are with two out of three
meanwhile in the junior section it is a
flip of the script for some of these
players but christopher you and andrew
hogg are certainly the ones that are
exhibiting the best chess as but they
are being rewarded with first place for
the time being two and a half out of
three for both of them abby man yamiche
with the comeback of the century uh is
now on two out of three on plus one
where he should be on minus one justin
one also in plus one but boy oh boy this
a wonderliang with half a point is
sticking out like a sore thumb it's
truly truly the 2700 the number one seed
coming out with uh
only a draw out of the first three
rounds and mishra is with
christian to explain what happened today
uh mishra first of all whose life did
you save before the tournament that your
karma points are so high
i mean this game i played terribly i
mean out of the opening i had a i had a
good position i think yeah i misplayed
and this bishop just got stuck on like
age two like dead bishop and like he
played very well after that i and in the
end there was this one trick he played
any other move i'm winning sorry he's
winning but
okay he luckily played this he spent
like 10-15 minutes too i didn't expect
for him to fall for this well let's take
a look at the game because you went uh
through it extremely fast but it did
feel like from the opening you gained an
edge did you feel like that as well yeah
definitely so this where did you feel
you lost that edge
what was the critical moment in your
opinion h5 i'm not sure is is such a
good move because i remember bishop h5
is one of the moves here but h5
it's a very aggressive attempt
like bishop h5 h3 king g7 a3 it's like
some reasonable position for white but
okay nothing too special of course your
bishop was on g3
his bishop is white that black doesn't
have a king side attack but yeah
so
he played h5 in the game
h5 i played h3 h4 bishop h2 bishop h5
queen d2 i mean maybe i could have
played something else instead of queen d
so i can play queen c1 knight h7 knight
d2 i mean maybe this is a better attempt
but it felt like a bit passive during
the game a funny move proposed by the
engine was actually in order to stop g4
let's go back instead of queen c1 king
to h1
did you consider this not really
and now if you take queen to d2 and if
you go g4 you can actually take on h for
crazy move
yeah not human
i didn't see king h1 at all i mean i was
trying to make this queen d2 and e3 kind
of ideas work
i mean at this point i
i greatly underestimated this bishop
takes f3 kind of position i thought that
eventually i'll be able to play d1 d4
and okay i might i'll get some pressure
on you
yeah but yeah i mean maybe knight f5 and
bishop d5 isn't correct i should
probably play bishop d5 first instead of
playing knight f5 and
so i can take on c6 go d4 directly and
the knight at least leaves on f5 yeah
after that
once you uh guys trade it off this nice
it did feel like this bishop on h2 is
just going to have a hard life yeah so
itself maybe actually after knight f5
queen f6 bishop d5 knight e7 d4 this
this was actually
probably a better attack four okay
because i wasn't able i wasn't sure what
what would happen here like and if they
take on d5 you take on e5 yeah like if
you take on f5 also i take on e5 so like
say bishop three gf3
so what if
they take on d4 now take on d4 i can
take knight takes e7 if dc3 queen c3 and
if queen e7 cd4 i get a better version
of the game
got it but also one thing is maybe black
might try leaving these knights on e7
and f5 like in the in some positions you
can somehow take on yeah like uh we
should accept three g takes f3 say
knight takes f5 detect c5
uh d takes e5 e takes a five you get
some kind of crazy position but yeah i
mean this is probably to be preferred in
the game mm-hmm
for you yeah for white
you have a queen five yeah like some for
example queen f5 should be five c6
bishop c7 like white is not going to get
mated even if black takes h3 no this is
looking good for you yeah with the two
bishops
finally the bishop is out yeah yeah
absolutely and then unfortunately for uh
that guy he got trapped yeah i mean the
c bishop c4 versus bishop b3 i thought
c4 is maybe a better square so i can
play bishop one whenever needed
and then but yeah i mean around here i
thought okay if i play if i play some
normal moves like a4 queen c2 it should
be around fine for white but things got
very unpleasant pretty soon like we
should be eight now d5 is always a
threat
so
and if i play d5 he just goes between
seven and like this is terrible for me
because now both of my bishops are dead
oh my goodness
so
i took d take c5 to open up the default
like this is not
very good for white but okay this felt
like the best choices bishop v6 was nice
actually bishop d6 maybe queen e7 is a
bit more accurate with the same point
that if queen x85 should be six the
queen is trapped basically
about queen e7 uh if i go queen e3 you
go bishop d6 so
you kind of you you kind of get the game
this is why i didn't go queen c5 the
second time after you played bishop yet
very nice and
he did uh seemed like he was making some
advancement in the position and at some
point you felt like
you need to play f4 i mean this is that
was dead lost i mean queen d3 queen c4
this point okay i felt like maybe i can
somehow hold this but right i mean he he
he played very well like night because
he improved to the maximum and then i
mean the issue is even whenever i get my
queen to g8 i'm just not attacking
anything everything is perfectly
defended right
and
let's go to the critical moment guys
because
that was just
and by the way we fell for the same
trick oh sorry a few moves before
actually after queen f7 uh with this
neon e7 yeah after queen f7 queen d6
there's a very nice point if i go yeah
here queen d6 so i call bishop v6
there's knight g6 oh this is what he was
counting on bishop h2 queen d2 is just
made and
night goes therefore there's too many
weaknesses in your position and if you
take on g6 take on e6 well that's not a
trade you want to see in this position
yeah and i can't ever trade queens in
the same game too because now you're
just playing a piece down basically
and f4 he takes f4 f3 somewhere but the
issue is whenever i do that knight gets
d5 he trades off bishops
let's go to the critical moment so i
just tried to keep playing some moves
bishop goes to ca queen f4 but okay i
mean this is just like a fourth pure
desperation
absolutely and then
okay first of all
after knight takes f2 did you see this
idea from afar so you saw it when i
played queen b3 i saw all this stuff but
the thing is actually i saw knight takes
after queen c2 there's a like everything
wins here but knight h1 is like probably
the most accurate knight h1 knight g3 f4
just screams oh that's nice that's nice
knight h1 wow and what
what was your
reaction wha what were your feelings
when you saw him reaching for his queen
and then landed on i mean when he played
queen g that was i was like shocked and
i just started calculating variations i
played queen takes up two almost
instantly i mean i was i started
calculating the sun game from a bit
before so i had some kind of idea on
what to play but okay i mean you never
expected it yeah yeah
you expect him to play something like
i think nights yeah instead of uh knight
takes up two i think knight
what was it knight c knight f4 yeah
knight f4 queen c2 knight e2 just wins
knight takes g1 queen g30 queen g2
bishop e3 that's a very easy way out
also yeah
well happy monu uh that was just an
incredible victory for you definitely a
boost of confidence
going into the next round how do you
feel right now and
yeah i mean this game was pretty
terrible i mean okay i got lucky in the
end that's a different thing but i
definitely i need to play better
sometimes in these tournaments you need
some luck did you experience that before
and then go on to win the event
yeah i mean definitely all events they
every game of chess also requires some
luck you need in order to win a game you
need your opponent to make mistakes but
yeah i mean i this this is too much luck
well
a win is a win as we like to say here
congratulations uh i'll be money and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank you
what a round we had today for you guys i
mean we are we are tasered we are
exhausted we are confused we are feeling
a lot of things here i need therapy
therapy is incoming i think right and a
good dinner a very good dinner and by
the way the seniors which we are
friendly with
three-way tie for first between
christians and navikov and maxine dlooky
lugi being the ugly winner of the day
from this group absolutely
well tomorrow is round four it starts at
the same time and uh finish it off the
show christian as we are just as
alejandra said tasered
i'm tasered i'm in shock i cannot
believe my eyes first of all abimanu
then uh what happened in sophie maurice
suzuki's game is just simply
unbelievable and she was playing
confidently this movie's queen to g1
queen to g2
but if her opponent would have just kept
the game going just a couple more moves
give your last checks and then try to
find the best way forward she should
have done that but miracles happen and
we've seen two of them happen today a
lot of chess still coming your way guys
what around
good word good descriptions a day of
miracles that's what it was articles one
two maybe even three if you count jenny
for use guys
yes
we'll see you tomorrow yeah thank you
everybody for joining it was another
long day here at our championships but
man was it an enjoyable day to cast
crazy see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you